Hello everybody, hello, hello, hello, oh my god, it's time
for Pokemon Pocopia, yeah, all right, sorry, I lost track of
time, okay, yes, there was like five users there too, like,
four of them were my alt accounts for Splatoon back in the
day, I used to create, like, for my Splatoon players out
there, they're like, wow, why do you have so many accounts
or your Switch?
You see, back in the day, I would, like, terrorize Splatoon
lobbies because I would be like, oh, so I'm left-side dokey,
by the way.
I'm left-side dokey because I found out that right-side is
not, like, all the UI stuff is on the right side.
Yes, I would smurf on Splatoon because I got tired of
fighting against fucking God gamers.
So to feel better about myself, I would, by the way, I
would, I would all, I would smurf on Splatoon and also boost
my friends.
14, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would boost my friends in Splatoon and also terrorize the
lobbies.
about back in my splatoon days the thing is um um when your
account it has spmm by the way uh uh so splatoon has spmm so
the moment you can only play like but like you know like uh
for quick play matches maybe like five to seven six games
before like yeah five to seven that's right i got you guys
uh five to seven games before they put you in the elo put
you in your a predicted rank, but in rank, you always start
at the end.
I don't remember what was the, I don't remember, it's been a
while since I played Splatoon, but I don't remember.
Oh yeah, sorry, and one of them is my Australian account.
I forgot, these are all my alt accounts.
One is my Australian account where I used to buy games early
with the Australian account.
Because Australia gets every game first.
every nintendo game first so i wanted like get i remember
back then but i wasn't corfo um uh i think i streamed the
what pokemon rcs and you guys were like how the fuck were
you able to play pokemon rcs first and i was like i had i
got an austral i got an australian account yeah so
australians get everything basically like a day early
compared to everyone else and we were like how the fuck is
he streaming so early i'm like assy assy oi oi oi i am
australian for a day for the day um so yeah one account is
the australian count and the three other accounts are my uh
oh yeah one is one of them is called hanzo uh because i was
just doing sniper only in splatoon so he actually looks like
wait actually let me see i can let me say i can show you
guys this um Actually, Hanzo, I don't remember if I created
this guy on stream, but I don't remember if I created him
back in pre-Corpo days or during Corpo days.
Let me check, actually.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
My entire monitor is linked to him.
I'm actually playing through my OBS right now.
So the other one is named Hanzo because I was just like, I
was like smurfing, but sniper only.
So I named him Hanzo.
And then the other one was like IDK.
Like, I was like, I don't know.
like yeah um and then uh the forbidden name and then the
last one was the forbidden name which some of you guys are
gonna see when the bond's over but that's also an alt
account as well
um uh but no my main account what is the dokey one that has
been name changed several times by the way but it's always
been the account i've used throughout every stream like the
forbidden name was not the main account that i used during
corporal by the way i was still the doki account i just
reskinned it like it was originally john cena by the way the
original name for that account was john cena then i renamed
it to doki bird and then it got renamed again and then now
it's back
um because i would play splatoon as no the reason why it's
called john cena was because the very first switch game i
ever got was splatoon and um and i thought it was really
funny to like go into splatoon matches and be john cena and
people would like friend me and be like oh my god you're
John Cena and your name was John Cena and so I would
terrorize Splatoon lobbies as John Cena because the show is
up he's like killed by John Cena so that's why I called
myself he's he's real and and her name is John Cena so I I
was terrorizing rank as John Cena.
And I would duo us with somebody.
I don't remember which wrestler she was.
But one of my friends who was also a high-ranker in
Splatoon, we would duo each other.
But she was also a wrestler name.
I don't remember which wrestler it was.
But she told me because I wasn't really well-versed in like
WWE wrestling in general.
I just knew John Cena back then.
Like back then, I just knew John Cena.
is like john cena's rival so like we would do it together as
john cena and like his rival and so
so i remember which one it was a long time ago obviously she
changed her name back like just not john it's no longer that
name anymore so i couldn't look at my friends list to like
go back memory lane um golden thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i hope the australian count is called
emu doki they give the super chat golden thank you thank
you, or I think it was a super chat, thank you, thank you,
their time was up.
Her time was now.
Thank you, it was a super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh yes, by the way, sorry for being a little late.
I actually got everything set up super early, like two hours
ago, because, you know, this is, um, I finally got a switch
two.
I was very surprised with how different the original switch
is compared to the switch two.
And I forgot, but then people were like, not remember when
the first switch came out and i was like yeah like a couple
of years ago right the first switch i mean i already forgot
like when did it come out the very first switch came out in
2017 and you're like yeah that's a couple years ago that was
almost 10 years ago guys that
when i finally unpacked it like like two three hours ago um
it is surprisingly okay they they were i was so surprised
with how different the two consoles are because you know
like i thought it looked very similar but i wasn't ready for
how different it is also by the way i forgot to mention the
reason why i was a little late was because um i was catching
up with an old whale friend uh you know you know um and you
know uh we're just catching up because you know we're both
very busy and and uh and we were like talking for two hours
and i looked at the time and i was like four 55 and i was
like oh i was like i'm sorry i think i have to at the end
like we were in the middle like we were still talking like
we were still like talking about random things and i was
like i'm so sad i got you to go stream i have to go stream
pokemon pokebia i'm so sorry we will catch up later and then
um most like because like she was about to she's like it's
okay i was about to play fire red anyway uh so for a little
update for them for you guys who are wondering uh she uh uh
she's doing all right she's playing fire red right now um
it's nice catching up with her too yeah um anyway anyway as
uh so anyway the the screen for the switch 2 is like almost
two times you know switch and i didn't realize how cheap the
first switch was like i don't remember how what how much it
would cost but like i didn't realize how it felt so cheap
compared to the switch 2 like because the dock itself is so
much higher quality than the first because the first the
switch i got was when i first came out too by the way it's a
huge difference because um the dock is like chunkier and
more protective than the original Switch's dock.
And it feels higher quality, too.
I'm not shill right now.
I'm not shilling.
I'm not, like, in Nintendo's pocket.
You don't understand.
I was like, oh my God, it's night and day.
It's actually night.
Now I know why it's so fucking expensive.
Yeah, nice dock, bro.
Like, you know, I wasn't even fall for the proper I fell for
it for the Pocopia because it's literally the highest rated
Pokemon game of all time for some fucking reason and that
actually pites my interest because like I've never like
really been in a Pokemon a very long time because I do not
like how I do not like the the core gameplay of Pokemon
recently.
I feel like they're holding their hands too much now and it
gets really repetitive and like I feel there's no nothing
new going there's no nothing new going to the newer Pokemon.
games um so like um i haven't been like like the last time i
played pokemon was literally pokemon x and y even then i
didn't i stopped at the city like the paris city um and so
uh so i it like i was interested i like animal crossing i
like slice of life like sim simulator games like life sim
games because i loved harvest moon i loved animal crossing
so it really interested me me trying to check finally
checking out Pokopia because I personally love those types
of games um and I love Pokemon I love the creatures in
Pokemon I just don't like the gameplay of the main line like
main store like mainstream uh the main line of the games not
the mainstream um and the core of the game because like I
said I felt like they weren't revolutionizing the gameplay
it just felt like the same old same old but it's got easier
and easier um so it didn't like interest me I like Pokemon
Legends.
I love the Pokemon Legends games because I thought those
were really fun because it put a new spin to the gameplay
itself.
Anyway.
So like, also, you know how like the Switch icon thing is
the fact that you slide the Joy-Cons on it?
You can't do that no more.
I was like, it's so weird.
Basically the screen, like the main screen thing has like
two protruding slots where you just slot on the joy cons in
and it's like a magnet yeah it's like a plug it's a plug and
play it's not like the slide and play anymore it just it's
like it's like a snap instead of the slide it's so weird um
it's like it's like this little usb thing sticking out of
the control like sticking out of the screen yeah it's it
does feel a little wrong because i'm so used to like the
slide, the slide and play, not the plug and play.
Yeah, it's not click, it's a clock now.
Oh, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I miss watching a lot of your streams to find a new job.
Congratulations on a new job.
I'm not sure you noticed me not watching your streams.
Anyway, I just want to say thanks for inspiring.
I keep pushing forward.
Gracias.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm just happy.
Like, congratulations on getting a new job.
I hope it pays really well.
And And you're having a good time at work.
Also, by the way, I just want to mention, Xbox apparently
announced a new project called Project Helix, which
apparently is the newest Xbox console, which is very
ambitious with how they're doing right now as a company.
So I don't know how that's going to go.
But literally, they announced a new project console called
Project Helix.
So who knows how that's going to work.
More Halo excuses.
Hey, guys, that means we might get more Halo.
Guys, what if, what if we could get more Halo?
Oh, yeah, what other stuff?
I feel like there is definitely a huge jump in performance
from the Switch 1 to Switch 2.
I was not a believer because, you know, I didn't like fall
for the original propaganda for Switch 2 because I don't
play a lot of games on the Switch in general.
not a lot of nintendo exclusives actually interest me um uh
because like i said other than the spin-offs like i swear to
god i feel like the spin-offs are the only way things that
get me for nintendo it's like the spin-off pokemon games or
uh or splatoon so or uh or splatoon like the others i don't
really care much about um but like when i finally had the
switch two in my hands i did not realize just how much of a
difference the performance and hardware was the fact that
it's like it's a lot faster I was not waiting 20 years to
load anything everything loads so I didn't realize how
abusive my switch one was towards me until now I was like oh
my god it's okay you got this little buddy switch one like
nobody expects anything from you so I'm willing to wait 20
years to load a single video game and now that I have switch
too I was like I put up with this fucking asshole like this
deadbeat of a console I can't believe I put up for this wait
how much are they paying you yeah it was it was crazy I did
not realize just how much I was wasting my time waiting for
that game to load anything
but he's such a Funny little guy, though.
Anyway, that's all I want to say about the Switch 2.
I just think, like, it loads a lot.
Like, my honest opinion, like, first impression for it.
It loads a lot better.
It feels a lot better.
And, like, the performance-wise, it doesn't feel cheap.
I mean, I better not fucking feel cheap.
I literally spent so much money just for Pokopia.
That's, like, I was, like, better than that fucking feels,
but it definitely feels very high quality for the price it
is.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, yeah, it can handle, like, it can apparently handle
Resident Evil 9.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As an old Halo fan, cancel your gold membership and gain
pass.
Honest to God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you see the high guard folding and Jeff blaming gamers
in an interview for TJ potentially getting canceled?
Thank you.
The super chat.
Look, they'll just bl- Honestly, I will say, I think the
problem right now, which I saw on Twitter, a lot of people
have shared the same sentiment with like new game releases
is that people, a lot of people tend to not give a game a
fair chance before they review bomb it i think that is a
huge issue right now in the current gaming market because
like when when the hive mind starts hiving then like it's
ggs like at that point like there's nothing you can do about
it but back then when um a new game game comes out people in
the past didn't go straight into like review bombing they
will try to give it a fair chance before um before being
like yeah it's like stand back i'm about to have yeah and
yeah so like once when you get that mindset being like yeah
it's just concord then everyone be like yeah it's just
concord let's just review bombing like not give it like a
fair opportunity or a fair chance for it which not i want to
just saying high guard i'm saying like a lot of new games
that are coming out um yeah they might be shit they might be
terrible but i felt like some games uh didn't deserve the
treatment it got like being like kicked while it's down type
of deal because like some of them are just mediocre type of
games they're not like absolute trash but like they're just
mediocre they're just average but because um review bombing
um and like um not giving a game a fair chance type deal um
a lot of games just end up in the concord category or like
being like like it's the most terrible game of all time
I think Higard was just I was just It's not I don't I don't
think I think I just think like Yeah it wasn't the greatest
I just didn't think It deserved the Concord treatment only
because Like to be fair Jeff Did not do so well advertising
The game with Like with his fucking This is going to be the
best game of all time Like that did not help because he
overhyped it a lot like like like he overhyped that shit a
lot and I was like that I like I said previously about high
guard like what I mentioned before is not just geared
towards high guard I'm talking about like overall because I
feel like a lot of games recently too um not just like I'm
not saying just high guard but like a lot of games recently
that are just coming out um a lot of people wouldn't like be
like it's concord like we'll actually try to give it a
chance to see what it is and it might be us it might be us
but it's like i like we're going in with that mindset set
that it's full ass not just it's all it's just an average
game like i personally think high guard was just average i
didn't think it was the worst game ever made
average like like um i didn't i didn't think it was great i
just it was not the word i played worst games before it was
just average it was mid like but the jeff jeff did not did
not make it any better because he kept he kept hyping it out
be like you're gonna regret it you're gonna regret regret it
when you actually tried it so of course he overhyped that
shit he like buried it faster the game would have naturally
died i think the game if jeff didn't put it at the end of
the game awards or if he like didn't also also if he didn't
like fucking kept bragging about how we're all gonna regret
saying how it looks ass uh that um that I think High Guard
would have lasted a bit longer I think it would have lasted
a little bit longer than it did today like at what it is
right now
yeah yeah at least a year I think they would have made it to
a year but because of all the negative publicity um and
everything and also like i personally think like i don't
like how whenever a new trailer comes up everyone would be
like it's concord again it's it's like i feel like i feel
like there's more there's ass games but like there's games
worse than
It's like the Concord multiverse.
Not every game is Concord.
Yeah.
It's the Concord multiverse.
It's the Concord PTSD.
It's every studio's worst nightmare.
Be the next Concord game.
But yeah.
No, I just, that's my honest opinion.
like like recently i think also recently people have been
like review bombing um without giving not i'm not talking
about just high guard but like just overall like everyone's
going in very negatively lately on like new releases on um
if the trailer is not like i don't know it's just not just
trailer but like just going in and then like playing like uh
like i guess like 30 minutes or so and then be like and then
just be like whatever that's the worst game i've ever played
yeah it's just it feels very negative and i feel like um i
think like it's like it's you know it's not just like it's
just like more so like companies live service games and it's
like companies come it's just a culmination of companies
live service also live service games everyone just hates
live service games now but that's all the games that are
releasing now like nobody makes like rarely any game like
everyone just makes live service games right now it's just
whatever but it I know it fucking sucks like it just that's
also like what's causing a lot people being like I'm over
this shit we're all so fucking tired um and the moment you
see it's a live service game you're you go in with the
negative like the negative um like outlook on what the game
is gonna be because that's true a lot of live service games
fucking suck because the moment they're closed you don't own
the game anymore like that fucking sucks yeah um and that's
a lot of things that triple a companies have been doing
which by the way apparent okay so a lot also like for the
reason why we're having a lot of live service games is
because of covet too because during covet there was a huge
uh spike of um huge spike of live service games that were
popping off and booming and because of that a lot of game
companies just see that and be like, well, we were doing so
well when we did live service games.
So we should keep doing it.
I saw a recent article about it that a lot of companies are
now firing a lot of their staff members and closing down a
lot of games because they feel like, why can't we have the
same player base like we did during COVID era?
But the thing is, a lot of people during the COVID era don't
play video games no more because they're not stuck inside
anymore.
They're going outside again.
They're doing other hobbies.
activities so so a lot of them don't like the people that
they're trying to make the games for don't actually play
games anymore so that's also another problem that's going on
because they're so they're like oh uh oh how come how are we
why are we not peak like why do we not have more gamers
after how we hired so many people and released so many games
geared towards these gamers because they don't exist anymore
these gamers don't exist anymore they're outside They moved
on to the next hobby.
They, like, they moved on.
Why, lad, not go up?
So, I get, it's just, I feel like, I'm just not really,
like, I feel like, I think, like, it just sucks because it
feels like a gaming community in general.
has been having a lot of like negative attitude not like not
just attitude just a negative atmosphere too um like
especially like like there's so many things going on like i
was talking about it i really hate that you can't even have
fun easter eggs hunts or like community ran like easter eggs
or like um achievements or anything because it just gets
data mind like i don't like shit like that like i feel like
the fun in gaming um is like slowly like going down and down
because people just want to like do like the fast way like
you can't even have fun achievement hunts anymore because um
uh players are just going to data mine the solution to the
how to get the achievement instead of working together um uh
as a community and stuff uh trying to figure it out I felt
like it was so anticlimactic when the solution was found out
from a data miner versus like actually like working towards
a goal, trying to figure it out together, like, like, like,
you know, trial, trial and error and stuff like that.
Like, it's just like the overall vibe of it is just, I feel
like really a bit sad about it because I feel like it's
getting a lot more negative.
People are having more arguments about it, lots of review
bombing.
um a lot like people i just feel like that in general um and
that's why i'm happy about pocopia because we're bringing
back the whimsy again we're bringing back the whimsy yay the
fun and joy yippee
we're here right here to whimsy max
um um oh there's something else a kid's day days will never
understand the insanity of your classmates telling you about
missing notes or word of mouth right thank you the super
chat thank you oh my god this is another thing that pissed
me off pokemon leaks were used to be so funny um back in the
day so fun and funny and creative now people are just using
ai to make and stuff and I'm like bro like it's not even
good or not even like like fun like funny humorous leaks or
like something like oh that seems possible there's like
Pokemon leaks right now but like oh future like what it
looks like future starters and everyone's just using AI to
make like fake in-game green green screenshots you guys were
not there during what during peak Pokemon leaks when they
would just draw this they would post like silhouettes of the
starter and then you get the craziest illustrations and
there was one where someone posted a leak of like a
potential starter or like potential future evolution and
then the japanese text it would be like if you read this
you're gay like in the
but my leaks used to be art yeah i think my favorite part
was that one like in the japanese text if you read this
you're gay like yeah like leaks back then went hard they go
crazy and then the fucking like fake scans of like comic
books and stuff like the cocoa manga and stuff where they
would like make a fake scan of like um of the pokemon uh
comic series where they like show like screenshots of like
oh the future pokemon oh my god the fake magazines were so
good but yeah like i said it's just um um i saw one i saw
like a couple for pokemon literally they're all just like
using they were just all using ai um balothar they give us
super chat thank you thank you correction only triple a is
making live service games india's not and it's thriving
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you just
the downfall of gaming in general I think I think like
people are just tired of of all the live service games and
I'm also just tired of the negativity that comes because
gaming is all about having fun um like having fun uh uh into
messing around fucking around with the community sharing
inside jokes the little easter eggs making funny memes and
everything and I feel like you know this is what I also love
about Resident Evil 9 like all the funny memes that are
coming up because everyone's coming like doing all the funny
stuff with Resident Evil 9 and everything and like all the
funny memes and the funny mods the shirtless leons uh the
passion about it it's sad it did sour a little bit with the
data miners but other than that i've been enjoying like the
community that's been like just worldwide community too like
everyone from around the world all united uh all united by
leon
and like you know that's what like i miss about gaming in
general like the gaming community um it was a little sad
with like uh because like i was a little sad about like the
discourse regarding uh you know uh the high guard thing
because it's just i felt like you know like developers are
blaming um blaming us and then but then we're like what what
well why you blame us blame jeff like why did you let jeff
do this like and then we're just tired we're just really
tired with um with live service games and like uh with
overhype and everything
um i do think there is like a percentage of people that yeah
everyone's just pointing fingers on everybody but i still
think there is a percentage of people uh that still also
like i just i don't i personally don't i personally just
don't think review bombing is it because uh i think like i
didn't think that high guard i feel really bad for the devs
um like, you know, they lost their jobs and everything,
because of it.
I just, I just personally think like review bombing isn't it
in general, because I feel like, uh, they, they didn't
deserve to get review bombed, um, because it's still, it's
still their jobs.
But if you personally don't like the game, and you did,
like, you know, you played a while and you're like, yeah,
this game ain't it.
But, like, there was some really, really, like, really bad,
like, I would say, like, some of the reviews.
Because I read some of the reviews, and some of them was
just, I didn't think they deserved some of the things that
were said to them in the reviews.
I just think it was mid.
The game was mid.
I think it was more so mixed.
It should, I think it should have been mixed instead of,
like, overwhelmingly negative.
Like, criticism is important, but...
um i just don't think like uh there is like a point to where
like it was it wasn't just criticism um sorry thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you if high guard was in
place at the end of it yeah if high guard was yeah i said
yeah i said that too uh um if they didn't get like the game
awards at the end like jeff literally just the nail in the
coffin um on that game but i feel like if the game the game
would have had a longer longer lifespan it would have died
eventually or it could have had enough time to improve i
don't remember i because i think like what's that game
called um that got i don't know if it got review bombed but
like it was negative but i don't think i don't think it got
reviewed bomb review bomb but i don't remember i don't
remember the time span for it what was that game that space
exploration game no man's sky yeah no man's sky um they were
managed to bounce back i don't i feel like if they did i
think if no man's sky released this year or last year i
don't think they would I don't know if it got really bad but
I don't think they would have been able to bounce back in
this year if they were released this year because they made
a fucking combat comeback yeah I think currently if a game
gets review bombed or like if it gets like a huge negative
like aspect to it a lot of games just get canceled right
after because then investors because the thing about current
the current space is that investors um when they see that
they just pull out investing like they'll just pull out
they'll just be like nah i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
keep funding it yeah so yeah so i feel like uh um but i'm
not just talking about like high like if i'm not talking
just i feel like it's just like a current trend a lot of
games if they people just be like i don't fuck with it or
like it gets like a huge review bomb um they they just cut
off funding and the game just just stops existing and it's
really common for live service games that's i mean that's
not it's a live service game it's no funding no service yeah
um i'm glad like no man's like no man's guy was able to
bounce i just think person i feel like in the current
atmosphere of gaming i think if it did release when it was
released back then um when it was released back then i don't
i personally don't think it would have survived honestly uh
because especially i think they would lost all their
investors i don't think anyone would have believed in them
but they come back they did it they did it but yeah like i
think they would have lost all their investors that they
released this year instead yeah
but i'm glad i'm glad nomad sky um um was able to I was able
to bounce back from everything and be able to make the game
that they wanted to make um
um anyway guys I'm excited to try it sorry that was a long
that was a that was a long tangent there I don't but yeah no
I just the current I feel like the current state of gaming
is just it's just in a weird area also like oh my god I want
to say one more thing but like the us too.
Yeah.
For anyone that's kept up to date with like, uh, with like,
but yeah, it's just my opinion.
It's just my opinion because like, I was just feeling really
like, uh, because my algorithm, um, I've been trying to
retailer my algorithm because like, I was like, oh, I don't
like all like, it was just like, it was getting like a
little too much with like the negativity.
So I was like retailering my algorithm and stuff.
uh for those who didn't know about the int list uh but there
was a website creative regarding like people throwing in
rank lobbies yeah yeah i just don't like how it's like like
it's just rage bait like twitter a lot of people are just
trying to rage bait now um i just want to look at the
positive side of things sometimes you know like uh um uh but
yeah oh yeah so anyway I just want to have the fun and
whimsy of Twitter back the funny memes and the ha ha's and
so uh someone made a website where basically uh you can get
paid to throw people's games uh because they're going to be
on they would be on the bounty board um and and uh and it
got really bad who would have thought because they're like
our goal is to punish the people that make rank competitive
terrible for everyone so we have bounty boards where they
made a bounty board where you get to be get paid if you
throw some particular people's games that aren't like
favored in the community but basically what happened was
that bounties were getting higher and higher people started
throwing more and more to claim the money so it was like the
wild wild west and it got so fucking bad by the way majority
of this was happening in marvel rivals and the marvel rivals
community but anyway a lot of this was happening in marvel
rivals rank in the high elos and to streamers uh for those
who watched my twitch stream and you guys were wondering
like when i had like lucky zeal by the way one of the
biggest targets is this spider-man one trick called lucky
zeal and on my last rival stream on our last game we got
against lucky zeal and the thing is like the reason why like
he was losing so hard in that game and somehow my team was
winning was because he had a bounty on him so there was a
bounty on this guy so that's why we were able to
so anyway anyway it got so bad it evolved to the point where
um it evolved to the point where uh both teams were throwing
were trying to see who could throw harder so they could
claim the bounty so so there was this game where one guy
where the team with a guy who had the bounty on him had a
teammate that was hard throwing because they wanted to claim
the bounty because the bounty was 300 and this guy that was
throwing on his team had 60 deaths because apparently what
they didn't tell you was that the more deaths you get the
higher the tip you could receive so so so obviously he was
farming deaths because he was thinking oh my god i gotta i
gotta have a bigger tip because then like you know you get
paid more if you have more deaths so then then it became a
competition but then the enemy team um that was playing
against the player that has a hit on him, they started
throwing as well because they were like, you're not getting
the bounty.
We're getting the bounty by canceling your bounty.
So the enemy team started throwing because they wanted to
claim the bounty next.
So if he doesn't get the bounty, the bounty is still up for
grabs.
So they were trying to cancel his throw so they could
re-queue again into this guy so they could get him on their
team so like to read to claim the bounty so it was it was
literally a throwoff to see which team could throw the
hardest so they could claim the bounty so and this was
happening in top 500 slash eternity marvel rivals lobbies it
was it was literally highest elo of gaming so let me show
you a picture i know i should be playing a game i know it's
been an hour i'm sorry i have a lot of stuff to say uh but i
shall show you guys like can't be that no it was you guys
might be wondering it can't be that bad let me show you an
example of the bounty off like the throw off here um truly
the wild wild west all right so here here you see let me see
let me give you a better picture like here here you see it
the enemy team trying their absolute hardest by throwing by
having no tanks uh
and trying to make sure the spot so the bounty the person
with the bounty is the venom player the one his name is jit
word he had the 300 bounty on him so the spider-man was
trying to claim that bounty by dying 60 times because the
more deaths you get, they won, by the way.
They won because the other team all worked together to throw
as hard as they could so the Spider-Man doesn't get the
bounty.
The other team could claim the bounty in the next game if
they get Jitward on their team.
so this is the state of competitive that's what i'm saying
like gaming's just i want i just want gaming to be fun again
like rank competitive wise as well like even rank can't be
fun anymore like that's the it's the wild west now it's just
people seeing who could throw harder like it's competitive
throwing now because of the bounty the interest um
um all the whimsy is lost like and then and then so so um
and this is not the only screenshot there are multiple
examples apparently of this happening to other people who
are on the int list um it got so bad to the point that the
marvel rivals team had to make a statement about this and
was like, if we catch anyone recreating this exact scenario
and situation, you will get a permanent ban now.
So I don't know if it's all words.
I don't know if they're just saying that shit, but they
actually had to make a statement being like, we will now be
issuing permanent bans if you are trying to purposely throw
people's games especially if they are on the int list.
So, and maybe they'll do something about it.
I think it's funny too, because like the original premise of
the reason why they created this website is because like,
are you tired of people throwing your games?
Well, we have a solution for you.
Now you can throw their games and get paid for it.
We're here to fix the rank and make it better.
And then, and then somehow, who would have thought it got a
even worse?
It got so much worse.
All right.
Anyway, guys, now it's paid.
Now you get paid to throw.
Who would have thought indeed.
All right.
I finished yapping, guys.
I'm sorry.
I got, it was a lot.
things i want to talk about but now now we can finally try
out pokapia that reminds me um i guess i didn't have to
match up against what god thank you yeah i remember that
just doesn't happen not just in overwatch but happens in a
lot of like um a lot of tournaments in a lot of pro esports
tournament games um because like it's like they just it's
called sandbagging these sandbags so they can get matched
up.
They can get matched up against easier teams.
So I'm not surprised.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
There's also like, or it's fixed because I know like in CS,
it was a huge problem where people would, or in Rainbow Six
Siege, where people would do like, because like you can bet
on everything now.
You can bet on anything these days.
Like even the most mediocre shit, like the most, like the
most random things, you can now bet on it too.
There's a fucking betting website for it and people would
it's like you know it's like boxing where they will fix
matches and so they're like we purposely lose to get like a
huge payday um lali they give us super chat they thank you
i'm glad to hear a great balance perspective on the whole
high guard thing i hope the good devs who got five can mean
like the ex-ubisoft devs who made expedition 33 and made
their own thing they give us super chat they could thank you
i i just think like not like obviously you know it's still
their job and everything and they worked it's like how like
you know i do feel bad because it's like their livelihood
and everything they just lost it all um and um you know they
worked they still worked really hard on creating something
that they believe in and you know it's still they're all
people too in the end so i you know it still sucks that um
you know they lost their jobs like it always sucks for
someone to lose their jobs the most about it.
Because it's like the 2XKO thing.
It's not exactly like the 2XKO thing.
But I don't know if you guys heard.
But they also, a lot of the devs in 2XKO got fired and let
go because Riot didn't see the saw that didn't grow in the
rate that they wanted it to.
And because of that, half the team on 2XKO also got fired
because of what happened.
And And I felt really bad and I saw like tweets about it and
being like the devs were like saying like how they worked,
spent like seven years of their lives working on 2XKO.
And I was like, that's like seven years like gone for them
and stuff like that.
And you know, obviously I emphasize for that because it's
like they gave their lives for it.
And they were like, they like, they were just some of them
were fired on the spot.
and stuff like that so like you know i feel i feel really i
emphasize for things like that and like you know like i
emphasize for the devs themselves for you know trying to
make something that they were passionate about might not
work out it might be like you know it didn't work out for
them and stuff but you know i feel like a little uh you know
it's just it just feels really rough in that scenario and
you know i still feel bad um uh Maybe the real Pocopia was
the friends we made along the way.
Thank you, the super chat star.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Now, for real, we start Pocopia.
I do hope the devs do end up back on their feet and, you
know, finding, like, opportunities, better opportunities and
create, you know, maybe be in a dev team to create, like,
next big game that does really well and everything.
this time actually gaming are you sure i just get really
passionate about these things because it's like like yeah a
lot of people like you know we all a lot of people hate live
service games um and everything and i just um but i also
want to you know i do feel bad for the uh for like you know
for the developers and stuff um because sometimes a lot of
these games are controlled by the higher ups and the
investors and the board of directors and can't really do
much when the board of directors are asked all right yeah a
lot of people lost their jobs and that's you know never a
great thing all right we're one click fat yeah we're one
click further yeah how we get my high school history teacher
off like on a sidetrack and keeping there for the entire
class period griffin thank you the super chat thank you
thank you all right we clicked four times we did it we made
it we clicked four buttons oh yeah that's me wait i should
that's me oh dear it looks like someone needs a bit more
sleep I came here for Pokopia.
I got in passion state of the hobby on gaming.
So worth it.
Jester, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, sound guy.
I'm finally playing Pokopia.
Now you can help.
I don't know if sound guy is still here.
I may have bet we still wouldn't start 10 minutes, 4 minutes
ago.
And last.
Thank you for the super chat, Jester.
I told you guys.
I was betting for everything now.
Oh dear.
It looks like someone needs a bit more sleep.
Wake up!
If I had to wake up, you had to wake up.
Rise and shine.
You certainly look well rested.
Hmm, are you looking for something?
Ta-da!
Oh, man, this Pokemon music feels nostalgic, but new at the
same time.
Oh, there's my Pokedex.
Oh, oh, a Pokedex!
And this model comes with a camera.
Salvage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So we're doing snow in four clicks and now I think it's
going to be a world record.
Is this the town where you used to live?
It's so pretty.
What a nice photo.
Is that your trainer petting you?
You look so happy.
That's me.
Do you remember what your trainer looked like?
Do I?
Oh, was she a girl or a boy?
What trainer?
Wait, is the trainer me or is the trainer someone else?
I was late to stream, so I missed nothing.
JK, I love watching your streams.
Fun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But is the trainer me or is the trainer someone?
Am I the trainer or the trainer someone else?
Do I, okay, I want to be a girl.
Wow.
so your trainer look like something's kind of wait what do i
look like as a boy though oh i'm like i'm like i'm stealing
her identity okay the girl is cuter i'm gonna be the girl
i'm gonna steal her identity and take her social security
number interesting so your trainer you know the funny thing
in pokemon lore about ditto you know like that the stupid
face apparently like everyone associates the face as like
dido like you know didos are really bad at transformation so
like every dido transform will have that face but it's just
one guy it was literally this one dido that couldn't fucking
transform right and now he represents all didos now like
it's like literally that one dido um that fucked up and he
was he was that actual defect like all dittos like yeah
because apparently all the other dittos can transform
perfectly normal it was just that one guy like he one guy to
everyone he fucked it up for all the other dittos out there
yeah like this I see what else can you tell me about your
trainer the toky behind oh i could just be oh
oh this is cute let's see that's just too yellow it's like i
have like i'm like like the sickly yellow you know
i could be pink i could be gooey i'll just be nor i'll just
be like
let's see and then oh that's cute just be cool yeah i was
just saying like do i need more sun or like just wait how
does the gooey look no because i want to steal her identity
i want access her social security number and her like
everything she loves is gonna be mine
wait i want the I want the hat.
I like the hat more.
Oh, it's like an egg yolk.
Wait, it's a reverse egg yolk.
I like that.
It's literally like a reverse egg yolk right there.
Oh my god, it's just retro dokey.
Okay, pants.
What if I want to wear a skirt, huh?
It is, yeah.
I'm just making me it's like me when I was a tomato and I
stole her identity just like that good old days
there you go actually the pants I think a darker pants would
be better all right oh my backpack oh my god I have a mini
me too on my back
yeah I'll make it yellow yay I'm so cute Wait, I'm
confirmed.
Wow, you're a natural at transforming.
Ready to start your adventure with your current look?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
Envious, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The same Ditto Trainer came back in later episode with a new
defective Ditto that can only turn into mini versions of
Pokemon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's me.
Wait, so what happened to me?
my trainer.
Oh, I found quite the hall today.
All right.
I'm actually playing through my OBS, by the way.
So you guys know I'm playing through my OBS, but it's okay.
It's full screen.
Okay.
You're not a run or hold B.
Am I not running?
I'm zoomies.
Don't worry.
That's actually scary, What are there Pokemon murderers in
lore?
You know, like, you know, when a Pokemon just had it and
then murders, like, a Ditto just had it, murders you and
just takes your entire identity?
There must be Pokemon.
I mean, there's Sherlock, there's Pikachu, Sherlock Pikachu,
Detective Pikachu.
So there must be Pokemon murderers out there.
Is there Pokemon jail?
What was that?
Who's there?
Gazooks?
What in the world is a human doing here?
I didn't think there were any left.
Hmm?
There's something curious about you.
What do you mean, any left?
Oh, no.
They murdered the...
I knew it.
I knew the Pokemon will rise up one day.
Are you really a human?
Or worse, a Ditto frames you?
That happens in the Pokemon manga.
What's a Pokemon yellow manga?
That did- a diddo did that.
Like, I think it was like evil Sabrina and the Pokemon- Yes,
I read- I used to read the...
The hardcore Pokemon manga where, uh...
Because I used to read the...
What was it?
Koro-Koro or Koro or whatever.
And...
Yeah, Pokemon Adventures, yeah.
And Sabrina would have a Ditto where she would just commit
murder.
Like, Ditto would just commit murder and crime.
And then frame you for it.
Uh...
Simple Man, I think it was...
Richette, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm so angry.
Sorry, but he's making shoes.
I'm dead.
Oh, yeah.
Kodo, Kodo.
I don't, yeah, I used to own like physical copies of that
because they had, um, um, it was translated in, uh, in
China, into Cantonese in Hong Kong.
So they had like a branch in Hong Kong.
So I would buy it every week.
There's something curious about you.
Are you really a human?
Nope.
Nah.
Oh, so you're a deado, eh?
What an impressive track.
Oh, I just said, yes, I am.
I don't know.
I felt like he would murder me.
Fido beep.
Owner detected.
Beginning.
Mecha battery boot up.
Speaking of Pokemon, did you see Mecha Japan share the
life-size plushies?
Oh, yeah, I saw that.
Yeah, they're real.
They're apparently like, I know like there's some Pokemon.
They were like bigger than what you expected them to be.
Ballathar, they give the super chat thing.
which one.
But I remember reading a little fun fact where someone was
like, that's the size of that Pokeman!
What's that sound?
Where is it coming from?
Incan.
Oh, it's from this.
Hello.
What's in here?
You found a Pokédex.
It's even equipped with a camera that can take selfies.
Oh, that's a Pokédex.
I found ages ago.
It's kind of junky.
Yeah, I was already in pretty sorry shape when I found it.
I thought the old gizmo was broken.
It's like an iPhone 1.
I mean, it's literally an iPhone 1.
I mean, it's the original Pokédex.
But it started working just as you showed up.
You're welcome to keep that Pokédex.
I have the foggy's idea how to use it.
your human transformation really is quite impressive you
know if i said i was a human would he like believe me and
now that you're holding a picodex you look just like a
pokemon trainer could it be you based that looks of yours on
your own trainer yep bingo
i'm sure you and your trainer must have been splendid
partners did that trainer give you a name um oh wait i have
an idea real dokey
it's not weird right i'm the real dokey bird oh wait
I want to do real doky.
Ah, so you were called real doky?
That's me.
Real doky, eh?
One enchanting name.
In that case, I believe I also take the liberty of calling
you real doky.
Totally the real one.
It's been quite some time since I last laid eyes on either a
human or a Pokemon.
oh he's just a hermit then out of nowhere i came across a
pokemon in the shape of a human how curious wait what
happened to the humans huh you mean you don't know what
happened here right then come with me yeah what happened
it's so cute though oh my god everything is so cute oh my
god look at my wiggly arms my arms are way too long
Oh, the little pooch that's a sound guy.
Is everything okay?
I'm such a silly little thing.
Ooh, rocks.
I got a noink.
Wait, does that make it take the bushes?
Oh, my God.
Mine.
I can take everything.
Wait, what else can I take, though?
yoink wait what what the i'm perfectly real human being i'm
the suck oh my god this way this place was once home to many
humans but now it's well what you see What do I see?
The grass and trees are withered and dry.
And all those humans and Pokemon who once lived there,
they're gone.
But my question is, where have you been this whole...
Oh, there's a squirtle!
Squirtle.
Hmm?
What's that on the ground over there?
Could it be a Pokemon?
Come on, real dokey.
Let's go see.
No, he looks okay.
It's a squirtle.
Squirrel, squirrel, I love squirrel, oh my god, oh my god,
you I feel so Animal Crossing like, yoink, don't worry, I'll
come over, I'll come over soon, squirrel, I just gotta grab
some stuff, I'm sucking it up, oh, all right, there we go,
water, water, yeah, I'll help, don't worry, you can find
water in my stomach well I'll be God smocked if it isn't a
squirtle and they're all nearly dried up here I thought
squirtle we're supposed to have an excellent command of
water is there anything we can do to help did you notice a
speech bubble that popped up over the squirtles squirtle
said when a Pokemon wants to tell you something a speech
bubble will appear above the them.
It looks like the squirrel may have a pretty serious
problem.
You should try talking to them.
Are you okay?
What's with this place?
Where's the water?
Usually I can spray all the water I want.
If only there were another healthy squirrel around to help
me.
Wait, do you want to like squirt each other's mouth?
He one needs another squirrel to rehydrate himself oh my if
you think about it when they're using water gun technically
they're spitting in your mouth you use transport oh shit
okay don't worry i got you oh where does the water come from
where does the water in the water gun come from
If you think about it, I must say, I've seen better
transformation in my time, but it looks like you can use
Squirtle's move.
Can you use that move to rescue Squirtle?
Alright, don't worry, Squirtle.
Drink my water.
Wait, I need a good...
There we go.
Don't worry, Squirtle.
up i'm here to help you
do you win my water
i'm gonna i'm gonna square oh wait where is why cannot hello
i'm trying oh there we go the whole of that cat tap there
you go I'm saved.
Thank you so much.
I really thought I was done for.
I owe you my life.
Something's beeping.
Choose water at prey while in the water with jaws into a
shell when in danger.
Oh, it's weird to find.
Yeah, but can't catch it.
cleanliness, healing, cute stuff, group activities, ideal
habitat, humid.
I'm not building you a home.
What the fuck?
It's not habitats of humanity.
Oh, look at that.
The Pokédex still works after all.
Though it truly has been an age since I last saw my other
any other Pokemon do it for ditto.
That Pokédex days of being useful may be long over.
Really?
But that was then Times have changed I come to believe this
world was down to a population Of one Me Oh yes Habitat for
Pokemon Should have been me not broken by The Super Chat
Thank you But today out of nowhere I met the two of you Hope
spring anew By the way Where in the world would you have to
Have you two been up Up until now Hmm i don't really
remember too well i always used to take naps next to a clean
clear pond this time i woke up here flat on the ground maybe
i slept a little too much oh my god when when was the last
time there was how long have you been sleeping squirtle is
that so fascinating but this whole area is total wasteland i
don't know of any ponds around here Forget about that.
Look at this.
I see.
The ground around here turned green.
I bet it grew because you sprayed water around here.
That's so awesome.
Yeah, I'm going to say, like, how long has he been sleeping
there?
Like, he slept through a fucking apocalypse.
There's no more Pokemans here.
Oh, it's true.
The ground was polished, but now it sprang back to life.
It looks just like it.
Then in the good old days, real Doki.
It seems you might have some sort of mysterious power.
What do you say?
Would you water around and plant plants around here for us?
If you do, this place could become so much nicer to live in
like it was before.
Yeah, great idea.
Can I, like, employ other Pokemans to do my job for me, like
real Pokemon?
That should be, like, a thing, right?
I mean, that's what humans do.
I should be allowed to, like...
Oh, wait, it's a nice flower.
I should be able to employ the squirrel to do my job.
Oh, later.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, nice.
A beautiful bed of wildflowers.
A sweet, sweet aroma wafts around about it.
That is good.
I'm glad that I could make them do my work for me.
Oh, a study stick.
all right arrange tall grass and furniture into the right
combinations what if you tried what the fuck is that
supposed okay wait oh wait does he say more okay okay why
don't you try watering where there's a lot okay okay that's
i was like what do you mean what am i trying and the tall
dry grass can be restored to fresh cream so i'm trying my
best.
I'm like, that fucking spitting water out.
Everyone go into stasis until they find tall grass.
Prito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, Doki, what have you tried?
This is like when Pokemon lived here long ago.
Have you, like, thought about trying?
There you go.
Use your stupid tall grass.
You restored the tall grass habitat.
Yeah.
Or it tells the tall grass A perfect hiding place for small
Pokemans.
This brings back memories.
Back in the day, there was tall grass that's all over the
place here.
Seeing such fresh green tall grass makes me feel like
Pokemon might return at any moment.
Alright.
I mean, I can water the tree too.
Oh!
Wait, wait, there's a...
Such a big tree!
Wow, that tree was dried up, but it looks better now.
But we can get berries from this tree, too.
I can't wait.
Yeah, don't go into the tall grass with a Pokemon.
I am the Pokemans, though.
I got the vine.
Wait, how do I...
How do I water the rock back to normal?
I guess I can't do that.
Unlucky.
One does not just water it back to normal, I guess.
What?
Oh, there's someone in the air.
Who's in here?
Do I have a squatter?
Oh, it's a bobasaur!
Boba.
Yep.
Yep, yep.
Nice to meet you.
When I just realized my sound is like, my mic is so loud,
I'm sorry, guys.
It was louder than it should be.
This plot of grass is kind of small, but I like it.
I love leaves and grass and stuff, and living by lots of
green things.
Oh, Bobasaur.
Bobasaur.
It carries a seed on its back right from the birth.
As its body grows large, the seed does too.
Oh my god, am I going to get a charm adder next?
I became friends!
It's that easy, guys.
easy oh ho now bobasark came come around you know real jokey
ever since i met you pokemon been reappearing one after
another it seems you really do have some sort of mysterious
power i don't suppose you carry on making comfy habitats for
pokemon real jokey doing that might be make it possible to
see a world overflowing with pokemon again just like the
good old days sound was good wait my mic was louder than it
should be.
I hope, too, if there's anything you've ever wondering or
unsure about, don't hesitate to ask me.
Alright, Lobasaur, what kind of home do you want?
The ground here is too dry, and the grass is all wilty, and
it's nothing like, does global warming exist in Pokemon 2?
Oh my God, even the Pokemons aren't safe.
There should be a Pokemon that can, like, produce more air
for us.
Or breach the ozone layer.
And it's nothing like where I've lived before.
Can you help, Diggle?
Would you want me to draw a towel of grass, please?
I want to make this place way greener.
Oh, my God, it's the coughing.
Oh, my God.
We got to eliminate all the coughings.
That's requaza.
Get requaza to destroy the ozone layer.
I'll teach you something really neat to say thanks.
It's been recorded.
Press the... and then select the request to check it out.
Okay.
What do you want?
Alright.
It's just a tall grass.
I can do that.
Raaah!
What?
I did it.
Wait, I can shake it.
All right.
It's okay.
The note's not about thinking.
Like, get rid of all.
What the, honestly, I will say, what is the benefit of
having Pokemon that generates pure pollution?
Like, sorry.
I, what is, what, what is coughing's purpose in, in the
Pokemon world?
Wait.
All right.
Oh,
you watched Waterson.
This place looks greener now.
Thank you.
Since you helped me out, I'll teach you my move.
Watch this.
Second hand smoking.
Ta-da!
Watch out.
What you think?
That move is called leafage.
What does it do?
Oh my god.
I can make leaves now.
Why am I doing all this and not him?
It's actually purge to send leaves flying at your opponent.
But it looks like when you use it, it makes tall grass grow
on the ground.
I think that's very you of you using it.
that move.
Yay!
He approves.
I want a home.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's a box here.
What could this be?
Oh, I can't do anything yet.
The call grass that Bobasaur lives sure looks nice.
I'm kind of jealous.
Because I don't have anywhere to live myself.
Where did you live before?
And only there was one more tall grass habitat.
I knew it.
I told you guys the squatters are coming.
Crazy that this game makes you touch grass.
Also, hello, Doki and Chat.
Boy, I think of this Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's homeless, Doki.
He's a homeless Pokemon.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Boom.
Is that enough?
Oh, it looks nice and healthy.
Oh my god, I'm just making stuff for him.
And then invite...
Oh, okay, so all I have to do is...
I gotta water it.
Bra!
Alright, live here.
This is your new home now.
Wait, what?
live here live here oh my god bobasaur took it all he took
it all he was like this is mine now oh pull all right all
right uh squirtle this is where you live is that okay oh my
god bobasaur's like look my home no this is squirtle's home
deserves it there you go you can be neighbors there you go
you happy now oh this tall grass looks awesome hey i was
wondering think it'd be okay for me to live here in this
tall grass
no come on please i really really like this place it reminds
me of where i I used to live, then go back to where you
live.
Why are you here?
Is it you live here for free with no rent?
Huh?
No.
Please, I really...
Oh, don't be like that.
There's nowhere else around here where I could live.
Oh, okay.
Oh, all right.
Oh, now he's trying to pity find me.
much thought thank you for the super chat i'm the landlord
now guys finally a game for me i get to finally be the
landlord uh just wanted to say it thank you for you and the
dragons for keeping me coming while recovering from eye
surgery i was blinded temporarily but at least i'm not blind
forever thank you the super chat thank you thank you i'm
glad you're doing a lot better And congratulations on your
recovery.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Yay.
Thank you, Ditto.
See, he still gave me a heart.
Once it becomes their home.
That's right.
I get to finally live my dream of being a landlord.
Make sure you put a deposit fee, Squaredo.
like a uh five thousand dollar deposit fee and also um you
have to pay for the if if there um if there's any damages or
it's not clean i would detect all five thousand dollars
out of favor now that i think about it there's not much food
to be found around here the pokemon who returned me start
feeling i have to feed them too.
Back in my day, there are plenty of.
Oh yeah, and you got to pay your rent five months in
advance.
Lepa Berry is growing on the trees here.
Also, water, internet, and electricity bills are not
included.
So you got to pay that yourself on top of the regular rent.
Rent, by the way, is like, is 3K per month.
That's right.
Got four tall grass.
grass over here 3k per month you want cheaper this grass
here that this is 1k a month each grass adds an additional
1k to your rent do you know where this grass came from it
came from inside me press x to open and then talk and give
them the items Alright, eat this.
I didn't contaminate it with anything.
What's that?
Is it a present for me?
It's mine.
Ah, yes.
Look at this berry I got myself.
Alright.
Yes, for you.
Wait, really?
Thank you.
That makes me so happy.
Alright.
Let's see.
Om yom.
Alright.
Take my berry.
Take the stranger's berry.
What's that you got, Ditto?
It's for you.
I can have this.
Thank you.
There we go.
I have to feed them.
Build them a home.
And everything.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, my God, pleasant!
I only accept U.S.
dollars.
Not your Poke Dollars.
I resign myself to being alone in this world forever.
But thanks to you, Real Doki, it seems Pokemon are coming
back.
I really can't thank you enough.
And as a token of my gratitude, a present for you.
Ta-da!
What do you think?
My bag's too little.
Uh-huh.
This isn't the type of thing you can carry around in your
bag.
It's called a chair.
Humans used to sit on these when they were tired.
And since you've been running around all this time in the
shape of a human, I thought it would be perfect for you.
I actually used to live with a human myself a long time ago.
This chair belonged to that human, so it's got a lot of
memories attached to it.
It's a hair smoth for me to use, though, so I'm giving it to
you.
Please, take good care of it.
You used Stockpile.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Is that why my owner abandoned me?
This chair was from my precious owner with a lot of memories
and attachment associated with it.
Here, take this.
You swallowed the log chair.
Do I become the chair?
Are you even listening to me?
Chairs are not food.
Well, I'll be.
So you can store items inside your body.
Seems like this ditto egg.
right yummy memories memory delicious yum yum would you mind
placing the chair down around here oh my god it's coated
with muscle my body acid
where and then spit it out yeah put it here now then go
ahead and sit on the chair You know, I think I'll take a big
rest, too.
Yay!
It's been ages since I've talked this much.
I've gotten tired myself out.
Burr, it's been chilly now that the sun's gone.
You know, humans mean handy tools to keep both heat and cold
at bay.
It looks like you're better at transforming into a human
than you are transforming into a Pokemon.
Maybe that means you'll be just as good as a human.
and i'm making fancy tools too probably ho ho ho if you
could use that special power yours to create more nice
places for pokemon to live that would really warm my heart
well me it's always there's always other pokemon what about
me what about my preferences and my wants and needs
my tenant excuse me can I tell you something I found
something weird follow me ho ho ho what you suppose
Bulbasaur found why not go along with them and see all right
Bulbasaur what did you find oh it's the chest I saw earlier
see this thing what do you think it is Bulbasaur Sorry, I
didn't get into the kids' voice.
Oh, but sorry.
I think it's, hmm, a bed for napking.
This is a workbench.
You can make all kinds of workbench stupid.
This is why you're a Pokemon.
Have as long as you learn the recipe.
Try crafting something.
I watch too many Pokemans.
Or the first gen.
Stupid.
It's not for resting.
whoa that's surprising whoa that's surprising i guess it's
not a napping bed after all huh there's something stuck in
there and try me to try making something with the recipes
you've got you might be able to make I can warm up chilly
Pokemans.
I just need to find a Charmander.
And then, like, we can just use his, like, flame to warm up
the rest of the Pokemans.
A campfire made from gatter sticks when it illuminates the
area.
Bobus.
Okay, wow, that's so cool.
Um, what is...
Oh, my God.
You're so stupid.
You're my little, stupid little guy.
Do you think the Professor O'Neil?
Professor Tango?
Yeah, Tango seems really smart.
Okay, everyone seems really smart to you, Bobasaur.
They're, um, what is this thing?
That is my, uh, my X2 weakness.
They're all tangy and messy, like a professor, right?
So let's show that campfire to prof- I would feel like
Bobasaur would know what fire is.
It literally will kill him you should know that like this
would be like bobasaur 101 he's leave him alone he's a cool
little guy this is why this is why i never picked bobasaur i
was a squirtle player for life my word is that a campfire i
always pick squirtle or charmander Never Bulbasaur.
Thank you so much because of the first gym.
I feel like every time you play grass Pokemon in the early
games, it was like the hardest, you go through like, like,
like the hardest like fights of your life.
You're fighting for your life when your first starter is a
leaf, is a grass Pokemon.
Every gym, every first gym is like bad for Bulbasaur.
Like for the grass type.
Just as I was really starting to shiver.
Can you set it down here?
Mr. Broken Bond.
Let's blow some Bulbasaur over there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, but you can just play Squirtle.
Yeah, but you can play Squirtle, though.
Okay.
Well, I picked Bulbasaur.
When you can pick a water, Pokey Man.
Alright, let's put it next to the chair.
It's a tad far.
What do you mean?
It's next to the thing.
I want it placed here.
It's like, Doki is over, party.
She's against my...
She's against Bulbasaur.
Hey, Professor.
Bulbasaur.
Hey, Professor, what is this thing?
This here is called a campfire.
It makes the area bright and warm.
Man, Tokyo's over-pottyed.
Quite right.
Now that I think about it, the fire's not actually lit.
A campfire means fire.
I like Chigurita, but I remember her being so ass.
Like, during the first two gyms.
Like, it was easy.
I felt, like, so much easier playing Sindoquil or Toto Dile.
I know somebody who can spit it out, spit out fire.
I've seen them around here, though.
Oh, huh.
You've got a friend who can do that, have you?
What sort of place did they live in?
Well, um, you know the plot of tall grass that Ditto made
for me?
It was like that.
Like, I love her design, but she was so ass to play with.
Say, real, Doki, why don't you make another plot of tall
grass, like the home you made for Bulbasaur?
A Pokemon who can make fire might come by if you do.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's Charmander time.
Oh my- Charmander!
Alright.
Let's make them neighbors.
We're gonna be neighbors now.
Grass.
Oh.
All right, there we go.
He's here.
More grass!
Okay, let me spray water on the Charmander real quick.
You
could get it.
a real nasty and he gets a luxury apartment he gets more
grass than the others he's pokemon's favorite my friend
stepped on our tail once and got superman because it was so
hot
toad even though if you think about it the charm matters
voice is practically toad but instead of saying hi everybody
he's like char if he could actually talk he literally is
toad Even though I'm the one whose tail got trampled, it
hurts so bad, I was spitting fire, literally.
That's literally how he sounds.
He literally goes, Charmander!
But because all he can say is Charmander, you don't notice
that his voice is literally toad.
If Charmander is helping the flame on the tip of its tail
will burn viciously and won't go out even if it gets
vigorously, even if it gets out.
little wet huh you want me to light a campfire sure thing
stuff's like that no problem for me let's take me to the
campfire and watch me shine it's like char char man the char
and it oh yeah guys remember like his screams like there's a
scene we're like where he gets bit, he's like, ah!
He's like getting like he's murdered.
Alright, follow me.
You must have pressed while standing to let them follow you.
Okay, follow me.
Let's go!
Can you wait for a moment?
We will light it for you.
Okay.
Light it.
Wait, let me find that.
How's that?
I lit the fire for you.
Okay, now you'll find that video.
A charmander screaming for his as if he's getting murdered.
Charmander screaming.
Let's see.
Holy shit.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, Charm.
That's crazy.
He's like, AHHHHH.
how's that what is it getting I mean getting bit by a
fucking turtle
now that's gone dark why don't we call it a day and get some
rest thank you for the help everyone truly like in the wise
words I noticed you've been transforming me a human this
whole time could it be that you really missed a human you
look like Yeah, I'm missed here.
I'm missed not Doki, because I'm the real Doki.
Long time ago, a very long time ago, there was a human I
spent all my time with.
Beloved by everyone, humans and Pokemans alike.
Where are they now?
I don't know.
But I do have a theory.
A game theory.
They started creating comfortable habitats for Pokemon, as a
result, they began coming back.
here right i'd wager that'll work the same for humans humans
and pokemon once so they abandoned us what the humans were
like that's too much work and then they left us this world
grows beautiful again like what the fuck like it was but i
expect the humans will eventually return here as well mark
my words he's like sorry too boring i go asleep now you know
now that you got so many pokemon back here again i think
i'll share some stories about the old days back when i was
just story too boring i sleep now okay
that's me
that's me right there why is it floating i'm on a chair i
hover oh my god wait i am
tldr too long didn't read oh you're awake you certainly
slept a good long while it's already getting dark again
today plan to start searching for clues about what happened
to the humans in this old heart.
There's a human-made building over yonder.
It's in a pretty sorry state, but where I plan to begin my
investigation.
If you don't mind, I could use your help.
We might find something useful.
I can set fire to flammable objects.
Like what?
Oh, it's so cute.
They're in love.
Forbidden love.
oh my god you can't get together you're firing grass it's
forbidden that's cute though that's cute specialties why can
you give me a power up oh wake up i'm happy i'm happy to
meet See you again.
Look at this.
It's a rock.
What's that, Jetto?
It's for you.
Wait, me?
Thanks.
Here.
Yay.
He likes me.
I gave him a rock.
It's the simple things.
All right, let's grab the berry.
How would I know if I have to feed, whenever I have to feed
them?
Oh, there's more berries.
Bam.
All right.
Oh, they're playing.
tag does try matter know about this oh my god he's thinking
about her he's thinking about her his new his new girlfriend
it's forbidden girlfriend suck wait can i not suck this no i
can't unfortunate i like he said follow me oh here think
about wife
Oh, it's a destroyed Pokemon Center.
I just found out that in the new games, they, like, combined
the Pokemon Center and the Pokemon.
I found out.
I didn't realize because I never played the new games.
It looks so badly broken down.
I don't even know where to begin.
Oh, here's something.
I recognize it's called a PC.
I have in the foggiest idea how to use it.
it but it always seems awfully handy and then they
apparently because like people are playing fire red right
now on the switch too because they just re like they
re-released it on the switch too and um that's the thing
that i told you guys if you haven't been keeping up to date
with pokemans in a long time and like i don't even know when
they removed this but like people like a lot of the newer
fans who started out at the later gens were playing the new
pokemon um red and leaf green and they were so surprised
because like the 100 Pokemon got poisoned and um they were
like what's going on because they like they were walking
around and the Pokemon was dying from poison and they're
like what's going on it's because of my they didn't even
realize because that mechanic was removed later on they
removed the poison mechanic I didn't even know that yeah
yeah things were harder back then we don't get no we only
have one EXP share and you get that like almost late game
and only one pokemon shared that exp share you know what we
have to do to grind we have to we send in the pokemon we
want to gain xp send that in first and then swap pokemon we
have they have to learn rebooting pokemon center management
system please use the pc the pc is talking did i make it
angry Please, real Doki, figure out what the PC wants.
Yeah, my starter was always the most, like, void-boosted
Pokemon.
Scan complete.
Displaying results.
Environment level terrible.
This environment is not suitable for Pokemon to live in.
Oh, dear.
I did make it angry, didn't I?
It's also, yeah, grinding in Pokemon was so ass sometimes.
booting up poke life the environment improvement app oh
that's cute is committed to creating comfortable environment
for pokemon and humans by completing challenges provided
each day by poke like you life you can gradually restore an
environment to a state where pokemon can live comfortably go
ahead and check out the challenge menu we prepared a few
goals for you the future first challenge should be fairly
easy so please in my tribe.
And of course, those who complete challenges will receive
wonderful gifts.
Now go out and live your best Pokemon life.
Okay, I gotta water and get sticks.
I didn't understand a lot of what the PC was saying, but I
hope it will be useful to you.
I gotta grab sticks.
How many sticks did I have to get?
Meow.
all right oh professor my grandchild plays with tangela a
lot these days oh he was the professor's tan pokemon tangela
showed interest in any and all human activities when i'm
working on the computer he stares intently into my screen
with curious expression trainers would come visit me also
play with tangela by the items they use.
He looks enthralled by things like Pokedexes and Pokeballs.
Are all Tangella Framing With curiosity?
Or is this little one just special?
Pokemon really are Fascinating.
Aww.
His owner's dead.
He died of old age.
That's so sad.
I got toy blocks.
Oh, I guess that would be used to Most likely.
I can use that to decorate.
Teng- Tengela?
Is that how you pronounce it?
Oh, I got Pinwheel.
Oh, noink, my fence now.
Oh, I can take fences.
I found a trace of Pokemon.
When you touch a hint of a Pokemon habitat, it will be
recorded.
Oh.
What is recorded?
Oh!
It's a...
Pinmon champ.
Wait, is it only, like...
The first 151 Pokemans?
Or is there other...
Are there others?
Look closer to the place where you found Trace and compare
it to hints you received.
Think carefully about what kind of habitat you should make
to meet a new Pokemon.
No?
It's just coincidence right now?
Okay.
How many Gens is it up to?
I like saw the names of the newest gen and I'm like, they
can't be real.
I have not...
i was like what the hell you can mistake them for chemistry
names okay habitat okay you want oh i have that nine gems oh
that's cool
i want to make models for all of them i have i have more
recipes okay let's see I placed this.
Yeah.
Is he gonna come back?
I restored...
After Pokemon can rest your tired bodies on this.
Yay!
I did it.
You should come back now.
It may take some time, so feel free to do other things while
you wait.
Red Pokemon particular may take a while to show up, so just
let things take their course.
There's no rush.
Okay.
I'll just spit on this floor while I wait.
Oh, there's more Pokeballs!
I got 20 brick!
I'm so bad at terraforming, by the way, guys.
Like, in Animal Crossing, I just place...
I assume that something looks okay, and that's good enough
for me.
I do not even, like...
I don't even, like, attempt to terraform.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Delection of Pokemon Pikachu and other Pokemon Were
distinctive Tail-based screening Today's World, so much
about Pokemon ecology Has been explained through research
This time we collected a special set of articles Focused on
Pokemon Greetings
I lower the property value Oh what?
I get E-Mount Where's my mama?
Because where's my trainer?
hate me?
Is that why she abandoned me?
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh.
Gosh, me, real dokey.
Sleepy.
Hi.
I'm Paul.
Yay!
This feels like Dragon Quest Builders.
Oh, it's funny that you said that because it's basically
made by the people who made the dragon quest builders.
Wait, what are my clear challenges?
Oh, I thought I did.
Where is it?
Where is my challenges located?
In tips and tricks?
No.
Oh, wait.
I have a settings?
Oh my god, fast, please.
Uh.
Uh, are my other settings?
Okay.
Oh, oh, I...
Whoops.
Oh, god damn it!
Why does it auto to know?
Alright, yes.
Oh, you can only see at the PC.
Now I'm at...
Oh, it's because my Pokedex is, like, Gen 1 iPhone.
Oh, hey, he's here!
Okay.
Oh my god, turn around, he showed up.
He teleported behind me.
Boulder-shaped, tall.
Oh my god, it's the construction worker Pokemon.
I don't remember his name.
He's the one with the veins popping out.
Boulder-shaped and then tall grass.
All right, I need it.
Hello, would you like to live here?
Whoa!
Hey!
Oh, hey.
Wait, how does she...
How does it move, Chan?
Timbo-chan.
Timber, yeah.
Hey, want to join me for some training?
Actually, hold up.
It's about time for a break.
Taking small freaking breaks is the key to not worrying
yourself out.
We can train later, okay?
You want to live here?
Hello, I'm your new landlord.
The corners disposed with a combo punches from both sides,
then finish them out with a single straight punch, Launched
at over 300 miles per hour.
All right.
Right.
Do they leave?
Can they leave my...
My home?
My town?
I wonder.
Or are they like...
Do they sign the contract and then like they can never
leave?
Hello.
I want the sign.
What do you wish you had?
Seen any B-drills?
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I got any stone?
I really hope you could bring me two decent sized stones.
They can't leave.
You're stuck here forever.
That's right.
You signed the contract.
You can't break the lease now.
Oh, I got some stones.
Can I have a couple?
Sure.
That's right.
That's your fault for not reading the terms and conditions.
You signed a five-year lease, and now you can't break it, or
you have to pay a not 100% fine.
Thanks for the help.
All right, let's get down to business.
What's he going to do?
Hop, hop!
Hey, yeah.
Nice.
That was great practice.
The move I just used is called Rock Smash.
Yeah, I'm the Tom Nook of this new Poketown.
Oh, I can break the water.
I can break the water block.
box now.
Hiya!
Did I beat the horns?
Did they send me daughters when I asked for sons?
You should be able to smash the rock and gran around here.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
I don't put tall grass next to this.
Actually, I'll put it here.
Wait, I'll smash it in the Bulbasaur area.
Just like Naruto.
All right.
I'm so fast.
Oh, take pictures of special moments.
Okay, wait, I got a smash.
I'm gonna take a picture of you sleeping.
Wait, what's this?
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, but it's not me.
I'm not taking a selfie, though.
Oh, like here.
Oh, like this.
Oh, that's cute.
Okay, and then...
Wait, I want it.
I want it.
I like this.
Uh...
What is this?
What is the top part?
Change hands?
Oh, actually.
Boop.
I won't give up.
He's like, what the?
Oh, I got the fire spin photo.
Oh, sorry.
I wasn't taking any picture of you.
Nope.
No, I wasn't taking any pictures.
That wasn't me.
All right, let's...
challenges okay i need water two more trees and three more
sticks
nice rock pile yeah it's pretty cool hey ditto great timing
check out this rock pile you thinking what i'm thinking it's
really big i think i can smash it up Ha, exactly.
I bet a huge pile of rocks like this will be fun to smash
with rock smash.
When I hit the rocks above you, just look up and pow.
Buried rocks, giving you trouble, look down, and bam.
And rocks and metal, they got the old fat, fat, fat.
Try to smash up all the rocks, did it?
You got what it takes to be a rock smash champion.
I'm going to smash it.
Bam!
Okay, it's so silly.
I'm so angry.
Oh, hey, money.
That can suck.
There we go.
That's much more convenient.
Okay, we need to water another tree real quick.
Boom, and then steal that berry.
I hope I don't have to feed all of them by myself.
Check out how pretty night sky is.
I wish I could look at it forever.
What do you need again?
I did.
I hit everything.
They're not doing?
Wait, do I...
Do I have to do this too?
I mean, I guess I'll smash it.
I don't know how to smash these rocks too.
Is that not enough, ma'am?
Oh!
Oh, there's treasure?
We're treasure.
Wait.
Is there treasure here?
We're a treasure at.
Is she lying to me?
Wait, I think she was lying.
I don't think it was treasure.
Unless I just gotta keep digging down.
Surely the treasure is down here oh i'm tired guys uh how do
i get out of here
oh oh i can return okay there you go yes Wait.
Okay, yes.
Minecraft, you're way out.
Maybe the treasure is the friends we made along the way.
I think she lied to me.
There's no treasure.
Where the fuck's the treasure?
I dug everything.
How could there be more?
There's no way there's more.
I did, look.
Oh my god.
She lied.
She was like, just keep digging.
There's treasures.
Okay, well, that's just going to be a hole in mine.
There was no exclamation mark.
Okay.
was i supposed to know she said keep digging until you found
oh my god the treasure was the friends i found along the way
it really is the treasure was the friends i made
Whoops.
Well, fuck that fence, I guess.
I'm pretty... There's diamonds, Doki.
You just gotta keep digging.
Alright.
I completed the challenges.
Yay!
I got life coins.
Wait, what can I buy?
Make life more comfortable for you and the Pokemon.
Keep on living your best poke in life.
You can get human items.
Yeah, I was going to say, where the fuck is the human items
coming from?
I see, it looks like you can use items you receive to help
other Pokemon.
And my word, are you ever good at wrangling that PC?
I'm amazed you can use it so well.
Maybe I'll give it a whirl myself.
To earn the buy...
Oh, I can buy seeds too.
Wait, I got a lot of challenges done.
Wait, can I catch them?
please raise the comfort level for one pokemon you can prove
by adjusting different pokemon prefer different so try on a
variety you successfully prove one pokemon's comfort level
you unlock a new challenge so that please do your best to
complete the comfort level i see you're using the pc anyone
could leave that to you is it safe to assume you agree that
this area still has exactly a pleasant still isn't a
pleasant place to live if you use that human-like exterior
of yours to help improve the other Pokemon's comfort level.
I'd be very grateful.
Come to think of it, Bulbasaur seems to have a problem of
sorts, really?
Oh, that ungrateful little guy.
If so, why don't you start talking to Bulbasaur?
Why does he not like living here?
I wish I had a nice place to sleep.
Is the grass not good enough for you?
You are a grass type.
you are literally grass what do you mean you want a better
place to live look at charmander here his entire tail can
destroy the entire ecosystem but he's fine with sleeping on
the ground like he wants to grass home
yeah god for What's the grass for?
Here, look what I just found.
You can have it.
I got you a leaf.
Sleep on that.
I bet you could use that.
Oh, wait.
He gave it to me.
He gave me a leaf.
He literally ripped that off of his belly and gave it to me.
Are you feeling comfy?
Huh?
Well, um, actually, I've been kind of having trouble
sleeping.
It'd be nice if I had something soft to sleep on.
What can I do for him?
That's his rent.
He pays me in grass.
Alright.
Wait.
He can craft.
Okay, I gotta craft him.
Oh my gosh, he literally gave me his rent to make his bed.
Wasn't bothered.
But that doesn't bother Pokemon to snooze.
away just fine all right here's your bed maybe i shouldn't
have made them neighbors i realized like it doesn't really
all right here we go my bed
yay oh that's for you now that's for me yay boba
you see that bed i made that's right my bed that raises
comfort level
time to try talking okay wait wake up i need you to oh yeah
he woke up yeah i'm just giving you a test run this straw
bed is super comfy bed house look great from now on Thank
you.
The people's bed.
Yeah, it's a communal bed.
You got to share with your neighbors.
I'm sure other Pokemon would be really happy to put things
like that around their homes, too.
And tell how much a Pokemon likes their home by checking
their comfort level.
Place things that Pokemon like near their home to raise
Is that interested in raising a Pokemon's comfort level?
they're feeling comfy to let you know if there's anything
they need from you.
If you don't have what they ask for, check the shop and go
hunting for recipes.
Be sure to place it near their home.
Items placed too far will have no effect on the Pokemon's
comfort level.
You can press R near Pokemon's home to display the area
around it.
This area display will disappear or if you move away from
their home.
Beep, beep, little beep.
Congratulations.
Oh wait, congratulations.
You raise bobasaur's comfort level.
There are new challenges available at the nearby Pokemon
Center PC.
So like, which one is...
I don't know which one.
Okay, what is Squirtles?
Oh, they are neighbors!
What the fuck?
Alright.
I gotta pull this.
I got another leaf.
They are neighbors.
And see like the border of their home.
all right yeah level two shop now has a wider selection of
items new challenges are available by increasing the number
of Pokemon live here improving their comfort levels as the
environment level arises new challenges will be unlocked and
you'll also need a broader the crazy thing is I'm still at
the tutorial
and you'll see a broader selection please keep up the good
way and keep on living your best poke in life it looks like
your comfort level will work when well as i suspected when
you want to raise a pokemon's comfort level it's best to
talk to them and grant their request mortars will become
available at a shop as environment level increases use these
items to further improve comfort levels and create new
habitats for pokemon all right oh my god that is a lot
trees.
I need to gather honey?
How the fuck do I find honey?
Okay, I got that.
I got the rocks.
Place.
Okay, I need to make two more homes.
I gotta build something to help out my Pokey.
Oh my god, there's so many challenges.
I have to farm?
Oh, use...
Wait, roads?
Am I- my Pokemon gonna start to learn how to drive?
Am I gonna have to build a DMV?
and give them Pokemon driving lessons?
Like, what do you mean, drive?
my Pokemon's gonna learn how to drive.
It's gonna be traffic in my town.
Alright.
What's that?
A gravestone?
I'm gonna buy.
That's what I'm buying.
all right security camera what's this place one anywhere you
want to keep an eye on oh wait what's this yeah i need to
buy that actually i learned packing tips oh my god i forgot
there's car habitat sure yeah oh wait oh i haven't
discovered this habitat yet what's this
you don't need that i'll just give them oh i mean this is
cute i'll buy this because it's cute i don't buy the leaf
then the construction is a complicated i'm not sure we could
build something like that all on your own oh i have to i
have to like uh get like a build pokemon so so he can
actually help build me stuff hey diddo gotta set i think
there's something at top of this hill but i can't climb up
to see for myself.
Any chance you can climb up to tie places by stacking
terrain?
Oh yeah, I got a lot of those.
Okay, well I gotta put this up here.
I got a lot of these.
Um...
Boom!
Yeah.
And then...
Bam!
Oh my god, I can transform Tanya!
Wait, how come I can't pick it up, though?
It won't let me pick it up.
Alright, I'll punch my way in.
Oh, it's because I have no thumbs.
When I'm ditto.
A dousing machine?
Oh!
Oh my god, I have, like, those beepers.
What are they calling?
The mail detectors.
Wait, what's this?
whoops wait what is that how do I
oh my god is that treasure I think it's treasure ah it is
what did I get oh my god is that TM
wait I got a TM oh it's oh it's music oh
Yum.
Okay, storage box.
Oh, so I can put extra items.
Oh, there's another journal.
Oh, it's the first one.
I spoke with Pokemon professors from other regions and
gained a number of insights from my own research.
Oh, he went to Cinnabar.
Many folks have been very concerned about POS effects.
It is global warming.
Oh my god!
I said it was as a joke, but Pokemon Global Warming is real!
God damn it.
Kyogre and Grydon is fighting again.
He appeared injured weak, so I used a potion to heal him.
He seemed to...
uh take a liking to me and toddled along behind me i'm sure
what to do at first i don't bring him home with me figuring
might be a good playmate for my grandchild i feel like he
knew it it was real all along oh hey there's the grave place
the berry in here so maybe a gush pokemon will come in yeah
rikwaza what couldn't stop him this time Wait, I'll headbutt
this, grab some, whoops, grab some berries, eat a berry, um
yum yum yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, and then spit, start
spitting again, and then spit, and then you find anything,
oh yeah, I'm fucking long gone from that, I hope I get a
hunter or a ghastly.
Or a Gengar.
You found anything?
Yeah, I found cool stuff.
Sure did.
That's great.
Not having any idea what that thing does.
But I got a feeling I have no trouble figuring it out.
A huge weight on my mind.
Thanks, Ditto.
Yay.
Oh, wait.
How do I use this?
Dowsing.
Okay.
Oh, I have to find a Pokemon to use that.
Oh, all right.
Yeah, I'll go smash.
Jokey smash.
Yay.
I don't know.
Whatever quest did I get.
Build a leaf then?
Where do I put it?
Uh, you know, I'll give it to my...
Gen 1.
My OGs.
My first tenants.
Alright, you guys.
I got something special for all of you.
Okay, let's see.
Tri-Manners' home is here.
Squirtle.
And then, okay, I gotta put it here.
Right in the middle.
Okay, wait, where's Tri-Manners?
Okay, right here.
So all three of them could use it.
Right here.
heroes and some Pokemon to help out.
Then they'll begin to build.
Talk to a Pokemon you like to help and bring them here.
Don't forget that you know Pokemon like Timber who's good at
building.
Oh yeah, I forgot about him.
Talk to a Pokemon meets the requirement of the building kit.
You place and have them follow.
Once you're there, ask them to help.
Okay, wait.
Alright.
I forgot about that guy.
Alright, we gotta find him.
We gotta find a big ass rock with lots of grass.
Wait, but like, didn't my Tri-Mander have that trait too?
Tri-Mander.
Oh no, you can just burn.
That's all you're good at.
All right, we gotta have fun.
Not exactly.
My Pokemon team was just built off of how cute they are.
How cute or how much aura they give me.
I did not care about Eevee, Ivy's and all that shit.
All I want are the vibes.
Okay, there's grass here.
You're going to be next to this place.
Yeah, as long as they look sick as hell.
That's all I care.
Okay, and then...
Blah!
There you go.
He can live here now.
And then he'll sign my non-predatory contract for a 10-year
lease.
That he could never break.
All right, you should show up now.
Don't worry.
I'll just do...
Oh, a great photo op is happening nearby?
Where?
Oh, is it that?
I'm going to take a picture of that.
How do I take pictures again?
There.
Oh, no!
No, my photo op!
Punching past the sound barrier.
You've got the impact photo frame.
cool oh there she is all right come out i need you to build
me my house come out i'll pay you minimum wage you can't be
in a union get out of here and it autumn and your contract
automatically renews itself timber hey what you think i'm
pretty good with this lumber right you should watch me build
i'm a total proud let me know you want to help building a
house all right speak wow what a coincidence always carrying
square logs they help out with construction and they grow
and they carry bigger logs i feel like pokemon do take your
jobs i bet you there are protests in the pokemon world where
the humans would be like they're taking our jobs because
like i feel like You can pay them less because all they want
is food and housing, right?
Like, you don't even, they don't even need housing.
They just go into the PokeBuzz.
All they need is food.
You don't have to pay them anything.
So, like,
they took our jobs.
Why hire human construction workers if you can just hire
Pokemans to do all the building?
Dido beep, a message from your Pokedex.
You've earned a recipe as a reward for discovering lots of
Pokemans.
Yay!
You got a recipe for a storage box.
Yeah, they can they're just working for berries that I can
just grow outside.
I kind of wish my home was a little what?
Is a giant rock and four grass not good enough for you?
How's your comfort level?
My comfort level was kind of iffy just because he wants food
see that's all i need to do i just give him a berry and he's
fine they still need a trainer yeah but the the employee
could be the trainer just needs to catch a lot of timber in
the wild and they're doing what they love they love this
this is their livelihood their dna tells them to build
their diet that's their entire DNA it's not forced labor if
they're decoded they're genetically coded to build they'll
actually go crazy if they can't build
what for me whoa thanks it's in there they were born to hold
timber Planks.
That's why they're called timber.
They literally called themselves after trees.
It's their destiny.
They don't understand.
They love to work for humans.
Exactly.
Looks like there's even more Pokemon around here now.
Wonder what the newcomers are like.
How's your... Oh, he wants food.
Okay, don't worry.
I have more food.
Wait, don't talk to each other.
Eat my food first.
Alright, here we go.
Now you can talk to each other.
Alright, follow me.
You were born for this.
You were bred to build.
For free, too.
Just for berries.
Technically, I'm paying for his services with berries.
Alright, Tim.
get in here.
Oh, wait, I can bring... Oh, Squirtle builds, too.
Follow me.
Alright.
Wait, what does...
There you go.
Start building.
Build your home.
It'll be done at 7.53 p.m.
Alright, it's alright.
Alright, just leave the rest to us.
It'll take a while to finish building, so feel free to take
it easy.
and do your own thing while you wait.
Alright.
I'm fine.
Wait, there's another Pokemans.
Wait, but there's also treasure.
Who lives here?
Oh!
Oh my god, that's one of my favorite Pokemans.
I grew up with Pokemon Gold.
I think that was my first Pokemon game.
Is that a Gold or... Yeah, it's Gold.
Oh, hey there.
was I being too loud I can't hope it I just got the urge to
cry around this time oh don't worry I'm not sadder or
anything it's just a habit all
right Hoot's internal clock is precise at all times it tilts
its edge to an affixed rhythm I always had a hoot hoot in my
party he's one of my favorites that's right you live here
now everyone's working so high i i gotta go cheer them all
on too i would love he wants it to be darker okay that's why
would you live next to the charm man near then all right
knocked out was so cool he's so cool too when he was ashes
he was literally ashes carry during his entire arc when he
got knocked out like he literally clutched every single
fight he was in oh he's just a pretty flower bed.
Oh, he can fly and he can trade.
Wait, wait, can Squirrel Ashley?
No, he can't, Ashley.
Wait, was he shiny?
I didn't even remember that.
I just thought I'll not I couldn't, I didn't remember that.
Okay, why are you guys talking on the job?
Hello?
Go back to work.
Get back to work.
Why are you talking?
my exclamation point can i come talk to you if i run any any
issues yeah okay i don't know what to do to make it darker
for you you're literally living next to fire like what the
am i supposed to do he lives next to fire guys okay maybe i
can craft something no i can't unfortunately
He chose this place.
He wanted to live here.
I can't extinguish the flame.
This is Charmander's house.
Build a roof?
Oh, I could.
Wait, you're right.
Wait, there's stuff here.
What's this?
I'll keep smashing it.
Oh, I got a crate.
Alright.
this Hoot Hoot's house.
Okay.
How do I... How do I... Uh... I'm gonna build... I'm gonna
start building.
Wait, can I even... I have an idea.
There we go.
And then... Oh my god.
Boom.
There you go.
I gave you a little roof.
Wait, does that work?
I don't think that works, guys.
I'm just gonna smash it.
I have an idea.
Watch this.
Okay, and then...
After I suck that up, I...
Oh, wait.
I go home.
And then.
After that.
Watch this, guys.
Oh, my God.
He's going to love his new home.
Okay, wait.
Oh, he got...
I'll wait for him to wake up.
He wanted it to be darker.
Actually, I'm going to wake up.
up are you ready for your new home
wait is he flying what okay wait do you like it here okay
wait do you like it that's your comfort level what okay wait
i got an idea
now do you like it
what do you mean it's so dark how do you want it to be
darker sorry I got an idea there we go is that dark enough
what's your favorite berry did it when Colby had the same
favorites how's your comfort level But I think, um, where do
you live again?
I need to look where I can find some tasty.
How's your...
Well, I'm not at home, so I'm not totally sure.
Oh, shit.
I guess you're never going home now.
I didn't realize there's like limits.
It doesn't go down.
What do you mean it's home?
Oh, no.
Oh, well, that's awkward.
Oh, shit.
How do I get me a make?
Okay, that's okay.
Now.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
All right.
We can fix this.
Okay, we can fix it.
We can fix it.
He said he wanted to be darker.
So, and, oh, wait, he's up.
See, guys, I told you.
I told you we can fix it.
Okay, let me...
Oh, shit.
Ooh, that's awkward.
There we go.
See, guys?
It's like there's no coal.
See, I told you I can fix it.
How do I make it darker for him?
I don't understand.
like i oh maybe like he needs like a house or some shit i
just three of these i thought i bought one like an actual
cave okay we're yeah but he doesn't live anywhere that
provides a cave okay maybe i can i'm not gonna remove his
campfire that's charmander's home oh
Give me a carve, a cave.
It's really hard to carve one here.
I guess, like, here?
Oh, I can transfer them.
Alright, that's, yeah, you're living here for now.
Okay, I can transfer Hoot Hoot.
Alright, Hoot Hoot.
Don't worry.
Oh, I have an idea.
I'll build you a cave right here.
Oops.
There you go.
I'm making him his future cave Alright, this is his future
at home There we go That should be good enough I'm creating
it in advance guys This is where he's gonna live It's
beautiful Alright, let me do this There we go That's his
future home guys Right here
all right what else oh i'm gonna go check challenges i'm
pretty sure i've finished some challenges
already see you all
right let's let's do the challenges
yay the shop now has a water yeah what are you talking about
just taking a picture something cool i don't know what
you're talking about guys i could rebuild the pokemon center
oh that's cool but i got that i used to live coins can't
make lots of items what can i get wooden bed oh i have a
cast was it cast cord or cast form oh my god i have so many
shit right now uh what is that cast form weather charm oh
tells me the weather oh that's cute i like that oh handy bag
all the time we're having to open it so handy oh my god i
got better cameras too for my not creepy shots raise your
max pp pp up
Island what's that version care habitat hit I feel I should
just grab the hint stuff too I'm gonna grab the hints
tantalizing dining set all right what's this yes large
luggage carrier how is this
urgent care oh that has to be a chancey right there okay
wait oh i'm too broke for pp up and now no pp but can i get
mystery gift all right give me my gift early purchase bonus
what did i get
oh i got a rug sweet oh nice I guess if you got the game on
launch that's what you get oh my god there's link playing
now oh that's cool
oh can I make them oh wait
can I make them like do work in my island like employ more
workers on the island.
Oh my god, now I can put the rug on so I can rug pull.
Exactly.
Oh, and three.
Oh, wait, this is real time.
I just noticed that.
Oh, you could time... Yeah, that's what people were saying.
People were like, you could time travel in this.
It's not forced dragoon labor.
You guys were genetically destined to...
I have to work on my island.
Just like the timber.
It's like the timber, guys.
It's destiny.
Oh, there's a cave.
Wait, I don't need to make a cave.
There's a cave right here.
Wait, what?
What is this?
Oh, this is like...
Yeah, I could put him here.
Guys, don't you want to hang out with me and my Pokemans on
my island?
You think you can hang out for free on this island?
You think these Pokemans are hanging out for free?
Look at that.
They're doing labor right now to earn their keep.
Yes.
Oh, nice.
It's been built.
all right yeah oh that's cool wait that's not a house what
the fuck this is different from what i saw on here it's like
uh it's like the timu pictures and then what you actually
get it's like ai you know like you know when you're shopping
it's like ai pictures you're like huh that's that's my ai
there you are ditto the leaves dead is all like where are
the leaves yeah check it out it's we're awesome oh my god
it's like a little cargo box it's like check it's like you
know those renovation show where the truck moves by like are
you ready to see your new home it's like move that truck all
right there is oh my god how is three pokemans gonna fit in
here that's a wrap they're supposed to fit three pokemans so
tiny it's bigger on the inside you need to like it you gotta
be from really big Pokemon I like this better before thanks
for it you ain't mine now
thanks Gritta alright what's new request oh he wants to
alright what do you want that was a blast it's been a while
since I got to build anything thanks Ditto but you know what
a house is already living just just because it's all built
really why not you gotta put some furniture in it at least
three pieces should do the trick and they can't all be the
same okay humans are all about decorating their holes with
cool furniture why don't you try it you pick up any you
found and make sure it makes them at the workbench you also
get furniture and recipes at the pc shop so look around and
find your favorite if you end up with too much furniture you
can always in my pocket.
All I'm saying is that you put three Pokemans together in
that little bush, you'll be finding an egg in the next
morning.
Drifting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'll put a gravestone.
Um.
A rug.
Wait, actually.
I think the rug should be under the gravestone for the
aesthetic.
And then.
Beautiful.
oh shit you know this is sadder wait this would be sadder
toy blocks in front of the gravestone there it's fully
decorated there we go i did it i don't know when i'm growing
up do you think out be even awesomer than I am now?
Is it not decorated?
There's three furniture!
What do you mean?
Is that not enough?
And a rock.
Okay, no, I can't just put a rock there.
How about
put wooden plate under the toy?
No, I can't.
I gotta put a storage here.
Yay, I did it.
Now it's beautiful.
Makes place feel, oh yeah, it definitely feels just like
home.
Now you can live in this house.
Wait, I'm supposed to live in there.
I thought it was for my Pokemans.
Come find me.
You need water.
I'm sure I'll be able to help out.
I want I want to say it's average.
Okay, you want a toy?
Wait, I have a toy.
This is a toy, right?
Is this a toy?
Oh, yeah!
There you go, play with it.
Yay!
It ties everything together.
Wait, there's loot.
Oh, I found a trace of a Pokemon.
Illuminated tall grass.
What is that?
Oh!
I gotta find, like, little light.
See, he's okay.
It's a Venomah.
Oh, yeah, I heard people, like, try Madden Doe.
See, it was a myth, guys.
He's still alive.
Chat, he's still alive.
I knew it was a myth.
I knew it.
But yeah, it's real time.
I heard people say that you can actually time travel with
this.
You know, the classic set the time forward, like skip
seasons and stuff for Animal Crossing.
You can do that for this game, too.
Hi, Doki.
Thanks for making English making your home.
That's awesome.
Congrats.
This human is usually celebrated and gotten you home?
We should, too.
Let's party.
How do we celebrate?
Oh, I'm not really sure how you're supposed to celebrate
stuff.
But Professor Tanggrove might know.
Let's go ask.
Come on, let's head over together.
All right.
Don't take them.
You're not invited to the party, Charmander.
That's how he sounds like.
He's like, Charmander!
Charmander!
Let's hear what the chat professor had to say about the
celebrating.
Oh, what now?
I don't know if I like that in real time.
I don't know if I like that.
I guess they have to so that...
Because it's like Animal Crossing style.
So that each season is correlated to like the actual day and
time.
But then it's like...
It's like, so yeah, you're trying to play day by day versus
like rushing through everything at like I like harvest moon
style, you know, I prefer harvest moon style, but you do
finish the game a lot faster.
But they want you to take it slow with this game.
That's why they're doing it day by day.
So yeah, like, but then I know a lot of people are abusing
the time travel aspect where they just change the clock on
the system.
Because that's what everyone does for these types of games.
Why, if it isn't real Doki and Tri-Man, they're quite the
friendly duo.
How can I help you?
You know how Ditto finished making their own house?
Do you want to do something to celebrate?
Oh, I thought I didn't realize that was for me.
I thought that was for everyone.
I want to put my house somewhere else.
Ho, ho, ho, a celebration, you say.
I think that's a fine idea.
But how do we do that?
Celebrate, I mean.
What?
Well, that's simple.
Hmm, now that I think about it, how does one celebrate
exactly?
I might time travel later.
I don't want to be at nighttime the entire time.
No way!
The professor doesn't even know?
No, of course I do.
How, how, what would a human do in this situation?
I've got it.
When I have a celebration, you need food.
Food, but we eat food like every day.
No, no, that's what I want to talk about.
You need lots of food and lots of different kinds.
too and when you get it all together that's a celebration
well he has a TM on his on his hair could be an HM move you
really know everything professor but do you think there's
enough different kinds of food around here I hope I've got a
wide variety of berries in my home I just realized that's
his I think that's his owner's glasses and like it's cracked
so you know he's dead dead they're even some very rare
berries in her that i've been saving for a special occasion
i just dare say this qualifies so please go ahead and take
them it's quite the hall of berries to carry but i'm sure
you're up to task aren't you real dokey because it's like
why is it cracked hold it this is a celebration for ditto
they should stay here i'll go grab the stuff oh i suppose
you're right in that case you can use a cloth you'll find it
on the floor in my home home.
If you wrap the berries up in that cloth, you should be able
to carry all of them.
Okay, got it.
I'm off now.
Be back soon.
Alright.
I'm back, and I brought berries.
Get ready to celebrate.
Now, now.
No need to rush.
Haste makes waste.
Whoa.
Squish.
Oh, it was so heavy.
I'm trapped.
Goodness gracious, are you all right, Charmander?
Hmm.
Do you smell something sweet?
Oh, no.
The berries, they all got squashed.
I'm sorry.
So much for our big celebration.
Don't worry.
Don't worry about it.
Charmander, can I see that claw for a moment?
it this cloth chair but it's a mesh now we'll just do this
over here and a little that what is he doing what do you
make did he make berry soup oh whoa check it out this shape
that shape look like a ditto i got a flag why don't use that
flag to mark your house we call it a sort of celebratory
house present to you from Charmander.
Good idea, but I'm still so hungry.
Wait, so this means the celebration was a success?
Yes, this is a splendid celebration.
Aw, he's just trying to make him feel better.
He literally crushed, like, the most, the rarest berries
that he's ever owned, and he's like, it's okay.
I don't need to eat anyway.
He's like, also thank you for the red.
Thank you, thank you.
I got a great stream.
He's like, it's all right.
I wasn't that hungry.
Put it like this.
I got my flag.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
I found a trace of Pokemon.
Okay.
You're gonna live here.
Oh, that's water.
You're gonna live.
Here.
Yay!
Come out.
It's not for you.
Leave.
Come out.
Come on.
Come on, little guy.
I did.
I placed it here.
That's my flag.
That not good enough?
Or do I have to talk to him?
I guess I have to talk to him after I place it.
Hello.
I did.
Is it not noticeable?
I placed it.
Is that to be closer?
That's my home.
What do you mean?
Oh, it has to be on top?
Oh my god, it has to be on top of the house.
From now on, each of your life here will begin in this
house.
Place furniture, you're choosing to arrange the house
exactly how you want.
You can even live to the end of it with your favorite
Pokemon.
You can also select return home and...
Oh, okay, so...
You get lost on your adventures.
Okay, if I ever, like, dig up, down...
Okay.
Yeah, it's... Oh, it does look like a mystery dungeon!
Yeah, it does!
You guys want to see my crib?
Where's my house?
Wait, what is...
How do I put people in my house, though?
Wait, how do I put people in my house?
It's that people can live in.
with me i need to get like a i need to find a q-bone and
have him live that's not up right if i grab a q-bone and
live with me oh father i need to find a q-bone wait i wait
do you think like well i'm gonna check upstairs
all right we're gonna go upstairs That's perfectly normal,
right?
That's a perfectly normal thing to say.
Wait, there should be a...
Maybe he showed up.
Wait, is that?
Oh, that's just...
Never mind.
I'm just gonna take this.
Oh, it only takes berries.
I wonder if I can light this fire.
And then something will show up.
Maybe I can get Charmander up here.
and come down from here it's alright well damage isn't real
this building oh he's not okay I thought he was talking
about my building I was like yeah what about it oh real
dokey I see your house was completed
uh no Syaxes is along the way either compared to when I
first met you there's so many more Pokemon here the plants
are healthier The whole place feels like it's returning to
the way it was before, and it made me remember something
amazing.
It's about this broken down building.
Just wait till you hear what it was.
It is a place where many humans and Pokemon used to gather
and interact.
In fact, I'm really certain this was a Pokemon center.
I bet it.
I knew that.
Of course I knew it.
What's that?
You already guessed that yourself?
I suppose I should have expected as much.
Well then, do you mind if I ask a little favor for you?
If you recall to make the house of yours, you used a
building kit, yes?
You're ready to get your access on a building kit like that.
But for a Pokemon Center, do you think you could build a new
Pokemon?
I think I could.
Well, not me, per se.
I think I can get someone else to do it for me.
If we get a Pokemon Center back and running, this place will
feel even more like it did in the old days.
Why?
It might even prompt the humans to return.
I followed a Mewtwo philosophy.
fee um we don't need the human it's time you'll need even
more materials and pokemon to help you but based on what i
know of you already i'm quite confident you can do this
we're all counting on you real doki okay i need to get all
right be sure to pay a visit from time to time yeah
um mu2 told us we don't need humans Um, that we are our own-
we are free Pokemans.
Alright.
Check it out.
You'll be able to buy lots and lots of different items from
the shop.
Yeah, why would you want the lazy humans to come back after
everything we did?
Alright, gather vine rub.
I still don't know.
I know how to gather the vine rub.
I've seen them around.
Alright, I should be able to- New items!
What are they?
Oh, it's like for prices.
I wish they would sort by new.
Is PP up good?
I'll buy PP up.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I should have saved up for the actual Pokemon.
Whoops.
I could have saved up for that.
I didn't even see.
I didn't check.
That I have it.
Okay, a thousand.
Okay, I need to use the bathroom.
Let's go.
There's no need to rush.
You can continue granting Pokemon grants as you have been,
making them new homes and just taking it easy.
I'm sure some of the preparation will come together as
you're doing all that.
So you can come back to rebuilding the Pokemon Center
whenever you're ready.
Okay.
Oh my god, wait, am I done with tutorial?
Oh, you always know I build a dream town.
It's yours.
Okay.
It is.
Oh!
Oh my god, she's here!
Hello!
Get out of here.
Hello, Otis.
Do they evolve?
Or do they stay baby forever?
Ah, I pulled him out.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Hey, that's not grass, you know.
Oh, my aching head.
Gosh, you really gave me a shock.
Whenever I get some sleep, everyone always thinks my head is
Plain old grass.
I can make a knockout on it.
Um, if you're ever plucking grass around here, just be a
little gentle, pretty, please.
Oh, yeah!
I found it oddish.
Its scientific name is Audium Wanderous.
It's said to cover distance as far as a thousand feet when
night falls, walking on its two roots.
Okay, what is it?
All it can grow.
What the fuck does that mean?
Oh, it grows faster?
Oh, I can, like, I can, like, make, like, if I'm, you can be
my farmer.
You're going to be my little farmer.
All right, you guys, logs.
What about logs?
I got a question for it.
Do you know how to make a log table?
We need small logs to make them.
You can get logs by clearing any old trees you find around
here, but I don't know any moves that make the cut.
Here's a Pokemon called Scyther with all big old blade arms.
I bet they'll be able to Cut down any kind of trees, no
problem.
I don't want to see that.
They really can't handle eat.
I see them chilling in tall grass in the shade, like, under
the trees.
Okay.
Okay, so we gotta get a Scyther.
Oh, I love Scyther.
Okay, it has to be...
Alright, let's go get a Scyther.
You can live here.
We'll just make you all live together.
You'll all just live next to each other.
there.
Like, Toki, there's so many places.
I just want them all to live here.
Alright, and then...
This is the Gen... Yeah, this is for all the Gen ones,
except for Hoot Hoot.
He just showed up.
Hoot just showed up by himself.
Alright.
Scyther is sick as hell.
He's so cool.
Alright, and then...
There you go.
Scyther should show up here.
Alright.
Yeah, this is a close-knit community.
This is a gated community.
Gen 1's only.
Except for whoo-hooed, with exceptions.
I wonder...
I heard that Ho-O shows up, too.
I don't even know what my challenges are.
Except for Hitmonchamp, too.
Hitmonchamp fucking exiled himself out here.
Okay, I'll grab...
I can grab another...
That?
I'll grab the vines and...
Oh, I need to place more furniture.
And I'm gonna build something.
Yeah, but I need, like, Pokemon.
Wait, lumber.
How do I...
Okay, water.
I can water more stuff in Gatterstone.
I'm just gonna do that.
I'm gonna start spitting the floors.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Hey.
I already registered this.
Who's this?
Who's this Pokemon?
Oh, okay.
I already have you.
All right.
Yeah.
That should be almost enough.
I need, like, five.
Uh, more stones to gather.
Suck.
All right.
Yeah!
Oh wait, the vines!
The vines!
Oh, I can't reach it.
I'm too short.
Suck.
I ought to keep sucking.
I assume the lumber is for this too.
Yeah, there you go.
I can grab that.
Yeah, so Scyther can help me grab lumber for this.
Oh, Scyther is here!
Oh my god, he's here!
Okay.
Let's hang out.
Oh my god.
Excuse me.
Please get down from my house.
Please.
Excuse me.
Bobasaur.
Please.
Get down from my roof.
All right.
I got to pee first.
I'll be right back.
And then we'll say hi to Scyther.
All right.
Scyther.
Welcome to Doki Town.
The happiest town on the planet.
Hello, Sight there.
Swish.
Everyone wants to move to Doki Town.
Huh?
What's up?
You need something for me?
Sorry, but it'll have to wait.
I gotta get my hundred swings in.
Swish.
What number was that?
Also, AKN, Ma, Zechra, Affiliate, Medi, Nexi, Bite, Papa,
Neppers, Min, W, Rice, thank you for the super chat, thank
you, thank you.
Ah, well, whatever.
Time for a little break.
All right, what did I get?
Hello, Scyther.
Welcome to the club.
Welcome to my town.
It's a nice town.
It's like your, what are they called the small towns.
Those friendly small towns where everybody knows everyone.
The siphs on his forearms become increasingly sharp by
cutting through hard objects.
Oh shit, I forgot to... Okay.
Oh, my friends now!
By moving to my town, it's mandatory to be my friend.
Alright, let's see.
He and chop!
Alright, I need him to teach me how to chop.
You got any Oh my god, he can fly.
Oh, I forgot he can fly.
A town?
Is that what you mean, Doki?
It's just a town.
I'm looking for some sturdy sticks.
Any chance you've got two of them?
Oh, I have so many sticks.
I was asleep for so long.
My moves really lost his edge.
Figure cutting a couple of sturdy sticks might help me
sharpening up, you know?
Tell you what.
Bring me some sticks and I'll show you my super sweet move.
no way you've already got some sticks score that'll be a
nice to slice up think i could have him sure here take my
sticks thanks pal all right time to cut loose watch closely
oh my he's so cool bam look at that you saw that sight time
oh yeah it's all coming back to me.
That moves, cut, cut.
Think you can learn it?
Saita!
You use Transformer.
Holy shit!
I blaze for arms!
Bro, this is actually like the ultimate ditto.
I've never seen a ditto that can do that before.
Whoa!
Hey!
Nice job!
You can use that move to chop up stuff that's your way and
clear a path.
Not even logs, sad and chat.
Yeah, I'm basically the Terminator.
Alright, I'm gonna go cut up some logs.
Oh.
Suck.
Alright, I'm gonna cut up some logs.
Watch this.
Slashy, slash.
That's right.
Get in my stomach.
Why are there so many logs, too?
Slash!
Yeah.
oh whoops sorry nothing you can go back to sleep oh there's
something in the water what's in it
oh okay wooden pillar recipe all right more decoration that
i might never do
what what did i do
I don't know what I did.
Oh yeah, he wanted log table.
I already forgot the main task.
The main objective.
Boy, I was saying hi.
I was just saying hi, guys.
Oh, it's just one log.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, let's give him a log table.
Uh, where the fuck do I put this?
Okay, that's Hoot Hoot's house.
Charmander is here.
Um, I'll put it here.
There we go, Charmander.
Are you happy now?
Whoa, a lock table?
You made one for me?
Thanks a bunch.
You should make lots more furniture, decorate, or area
around here.
Keep it stuff wherever you want.
You know, I've had tons of other Pokemon probably like that
too.
Only if they ask.
Only if it benefits me.
I'll do it.
Okay, I think I can build.
I'm pretty sure I can build the Pokemon Center now.
I've done a lot of tasks.
Okay.
Complete.
Where's the suck one?
Am I not gathered enough sturdy sticks and rocks?
Oh my god.
If I didn't spend it on my PP up.
Wait, should I use it?
Oh my.
Alright, it's okay.
Maybe...
There has to be more rocks around here.
Oh wait.
Cut!
Suck.
The cut and suck.
I found traces of Pokemon.
Oh!
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I need to be sunny?
Okay, I don't have money for that yet.
Wait, we need to...
Lumber.
I need to find sticks.
I don't want lumber.
Yeah, it is James's girlfriend.
Okay.
That was a game.
I'm having fun.
It definitely feels...
It's more...
It's like...
Animal Crossing with...
I personally feel like it's like Animal Crossing with
Minecraft.
But you have to do it day by day.
You can't like...
They make it so that...
It's more so that you do it day by day versus like trying to
complete it as much as you can in one setting type deal.
Yeah.
What?
It's Ho-O!
Yes!
Wait, why doesn't it not show like an achievement?
It's literally Ho-O!
Oh my gosh, it's freezing fireballs.
Wait, where is the landing?
Wait, there's something over there!
Okay, I might need the blocks.
Oh, shit.
Um, eh.
Eh.
Wait, there's something over there.
He dropped it all the way there.
Wait, there's a...
Oh, what is this?
It's the feather!
Um...
Oh, it's too hot.
Oh, shit.
Yo, where am I?
Yay!
The shines looks like it fell.
What can I do with it?
Where's the feather?
Yo.
I like that.
It's like, yo, where am I?
What can I do with it?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I can always watch my people.
Or check if a new Pokemon has appeared.
Oh hey, there's a fishing ride.
Does that mean I can catch?
Oh!
I can catch other fishes.
Other Pokemon.
What's this?
Oh, it's a slowpoke!
Okay.
Are you guys okay?
Hey there.
Nice to meet you.
I'm just a humble little mage cop.
Yo, and I suddenly just found myself here.
Laughing and splashing about, yo.
I'm Skylar.
I'm Skylar White, yo.
Can't remember anything before that, yo.
And you're, wait, don't tell me.
You're Ditto, right?
Yo, I'm so glad to get to meet you.
I hope we can be friends, yo.
that's i feel i'm scouting what yo an underpowered pathetic
pokemon it may jump on rare occasion but never more than
seven feet oh it has no specialty he's just exist all right
you live here now i can teach you something awesome what
splash so i'll maybe get you to help me with something I'm
missing the place I used to live, yo.
Is this what being homestick feels like?
Anyways, basically, I'll be super happy.
You can make me feel, make me a home kind of like this.
Alright.
What?
Oh, I need a chair.
Okay.
Teach you one of my best moves.
I wonder what that is.
Let's cut this first.
Cut!
Suck.
The cut and suck.
To my fishing fanatic, big bro.
By the way, have Pokemon started changing where they live?
Where should I fish that Pokemon that used to only see in
different regions?
Maybe you'll catch something rare where you are too.
How do I fish?
Oh, it's a toy!
Wait, it went down here.
That's not what I wanted.
Uh...
Wait, once...
I haven't discovered this habitat yet?
Okay, I need...
Oh, I can't see anything.
I'm playing through my OBS right now.
I need...
What do I need?
Ocean water?
fishing rod and oh I do have that I might just build this
myself I mean this is the sand and I need to build a seat oh
nice oh nice okay I just need to build a log
seat all right let's build that And then, put this right
here, yo.
Yay!
Magikot.
I got you your habitat.
Alright.
Show me your...
Oh, I must be able to be a...
Lapras now!
Yo, thank you so much, Ditto.
I'm totally grateful for the awesome home you made me.
Alright, cool.
Now I'll teach you what my best moves...
as promised.
You gotta watch closely while I do it, yo.
Why does Magic Cart need a chair?
So he can...
So he can splash on it.
Blop.
Blop, blop, blop.
There it is.
That is one of my best moves, yo.
At the very least, hopping up on short ledges and things
should be no problem to you now.
I mean, it's pretty much only good for short ledges and
things, but it's pretty cool, right?
oh my god never mind never mind he's just as pathetic as i
remember sick moves to be honest you learn how to jump yay
okay i can jump now yay i can't believe i my legs didn't
know how to do that before wow i can't believe it my legs
did not know how to move like that before until the Magikarp
caught me splash.
What would I do without it?
Alright, seaside.
I need ocean water, too.
Oh, I just need four pieces of grass.
That's easy.
That's already four over there.
Alright, Magikarp.
You're sharing it with Snowpoke.
That's alright.
You guys are just like...
You guys are made for each other.
all right nice all right snow poke shit come up oh yeah for
the guy wondering what the chair is for
for all the people that wondered what it was for i guess
here's your answer
oh he went back to sleep he's like oh that was nothing what
was that oh just the wind do i have enough now oh yeah i was
trying to find rocks almost forgot my mission
suck i literally need rocks and sticks oh my god there's so
many oh nice okay now i just need sticks yeah but in pokemon
lore we eat magic art We literally make lots of food out of
Magikarp.
Oh, is he here yet?
No, the slowpoke isn't here yet.
Oh my god, am I not...
How many more sticks do I need?
Where are all the sticks?
It's like...
It's like the...
What's it called?
Pufferfish.
Oh, oh, it's this guy.
You only eat a little bit of...
If you only cut it right, you can eat the magic cart.
You gotta be a really good chef to make it work.
Okay, I need to eat more berries.
Oh, that's not what I want.
Alright, I'm yam yam yam.
I'm yam yam.
Ditto doesn't need sleep.
Smash!
All I need are berries.
to sustain myself.
Oh, there's sticks.
Makes me feel like there's no sticks in this rock area.
Oh, open.
Maybe this would be helpful.
Does this do anything?
Oh, that's cool.
I made like little...
There's like little grates there.
Crackle, peep, peep.
Oh, maybe the end game is we're at the...
For Endgame, we have to, like, set up the radio tower or
something.
It's, like, raft, and then you call the humans back and be,
like, come back!
We can live here now!
We have a safe haven!
Oh, nice.
There must be more sticks here somewhere.
I'm having a lot of fun, though.
I can see myself just playing, like, booting this up.
Not every day, but, like, every couple of days.
I don't know if I can chop trees for sticks, but I'll try.
No, I can't chop these.
These I have to water it back.
Oh, there's more areas here.
I got a recipe for a wooden bench.
All right, what kind of Pokemon lives here?
Oh!
It's a belt.
Weeping Bell.
Oh, I need for that.
That big-ass head is covering this.
See, and a small...
Okay, I don't have a small vase.
I don't have a crafting thing for that.
I think I have to buy that.
God damn it.
It's James's other girlfriend.
And you can build a lot of shit, apparently.
Like, uh...
Oh, it's time to dig.
Like, the one where I said...
like some during the demonstration the guy literally built a
fucking roller coaster in a music box what's this oh a last
relic okay i can get it praised dear elena elana look at my
little mini and cc this is the best shot i've ever taken of
them i've been thinking about them lately day and night what
are you supposed to up to i just keep at this photo.
You told me about your partner before, right, Ilana?
Wasn't it named Mora or something?
I bet it was cute.
Just like its trainer.
Wish I could...
Oh!
What happened to Mora?
No!
Oh, hey, a garden.
Oh.
That's sad.
Beans.
It's okay.
I got beans, though.
I got my beans, though.
Oh.
Dig time.
Dig.
Oh, is that another relic?
Oh, nice.
Oh, um.
What have carrot?
When the fuck did I get carrot?
from uh what do i not need all of this is important to me i
guess dry field look it
oh this is my only attempt at terraforming all right we
gotta get back wait maybe the slow poke is here now oh no
i'm stuck oh wait i could jump silly dokey you're never so
stick All right, let's see the Slowpoke finally spawned in.
Who is that?
There's your books!
Oh!
I found Trace as a Pokemon.
Oh my god, it's Hitman!
Hitman Lee!
My Jackie Chan with my Bruce Lee.
What do I need?
Table?
Seat and first aid kit.
Oh yeah, because he's too busy beating people.
up it's not for him it's for his victims oh my god this was
an actual house what happened to the house why is that did a
fucking meteor did that fucking nuke or meteor drop on this
on this island what happened to it
yeah I need a oh there's another another lawyer like the
arts RC just got mad it caught raccoon city.
Oh!
That's cute.
Wait, what's over there?
Is that Jim over there?
I like the little lore.
Like, everywhere.
See, there's, like, the little lore around the island.
Yeah, Arceus got really mad.
It's like Noah's Ark.
He sent a meteor to this island.
Honestly, Honestly, yeah, you're right.
It doesn't happen more often in the Pokemon world.
There's a lot of things to be mad about for Arceus.
Yeah, I was going to say, was that CC and Mimi?
I thought about it, too.
I think it was Super Chat Envious.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah, I could buy it now.
I should be able to buy the Pokemon Centurio.
Yes, please.
One Pokemon Center, please.
Like, today is a bad day!
Fuck that one city in particular.
Alright, build my Pokemon Center.
You need help from Pokemon as a Borgdose specialty.
Who's large and hard like a bully.
I don't have that.
Nobody moved to Doki Town yet.
Rocky plays like a cave.
Okay, I need like a cave environment.
there squirtle what is up there do you have a moment
squirtle see I spotted this path between the cliffs I'm
really curious about where it leads to I was wondering when
I go check it out with me did oh I mean it's not like I'm
scared or anything okay I just thought I'd ask okay sure I
need to put some stuff away first let's see where this path
take us you can lead the way diddo You gotta take them.
Alright, come with me to my house first.
Let me show you to my crib.
My beautiful house.
Alright, let's see.
I don't need this.
I don't need...
Oh, no, I not need.
Okay, I don't need all these CDs in my house.
Because I don't have a music player yet.
Oh, we're gonna grab...
Um...
Oh, I just pressed B.
Okay.
Wait, not B.
Why?
So why?
Yeah, add stack.
I don't need the grasses.
Oh, restores pee pee when eating.
Okay.
Put all of this away.
No, I built that grave.
Alright, we'll keep all of this for now.
Alright, let's leave.
Alright, we gotta uh...
all right appraise my relics uh look at this what is this
hey what you got here appraise this what is this
oh I've got it a wiggly mirror you must use this a long ago
I have the foggy to see how to use it though it could be fun
to use as a decoration in your house.
Oh, it's those, like, uh, funny mirrors.
Or you could place it near a Pokemon home.
They might really like it.
Alright.
Ah, it's like the, it's like the museum type thing, but for
decoration.
Praise this.
What is this?
Are human?
We don't know yet.
We're, we're trying to figure this out right now.
If they're actually gone forever.
This is without a doubt a Wabafet Wobbler.
It's like Splatoon where all the humans are dead.
Is there anything else?
No, I'm done.
Alright, let's put this away.
Oh!
Wait!
Hitmon Lee or Hitmonchan will like this.
I'll give this to Hitmonchan.
That's something you could do for training.
Oh, and Pikmin, too, yeah.
Here you go.
Wait, oops.
Okay, wait.
Boom.
There we go.
All right, let's go do the thing, Squaredo.
You want me to clear you a path?
Watch this.
Oh, there you go.
You're welcome.
Okay, why did you want to come here?
Wow, look at that.
It's a big, huge beach.
It feels so nice here.
I'm glad we made it.
Oh, look.
There's a cave over there.
It looks way too scary, though.
here you coward you wanted to be here oh rare mushrooms oh
my god we're gonna get the mushroom guy i'm still not going
anywhere near that cave though it's way too spooky thanks
for bringing me here though oh my god you got that oh he's
gonna duck the kids oh hello oh hi nice oh yeah what's he
gonna do?
If all the humans are gone, who is he gonna kidnap now?
You know, I really like a nice squirrel, too.
There's no more kids to a duck!
I bet it'd be lots of fun if we traveled together, don't you
think?
Why do you want to travel together?
Is it because I'm kid-sized?
Cause it's a signpost of wonder spirits where do I find it
oh I don't know dream island spooky stuff what does it like
spooky he's trying to kidnap me oh no oh hey road closure
has been added to my human oh what the fuck where the fuck
is that oh my god cycling road will be closed on the 7th for
inspection the road not be accessible to the public so we
recommend making you recommend making your travel plans
early i'm gonna go check that island i apparently i sink to
the bottom did i die oh oh shit wait i can make it i just
gotta keep jumping there we go there you go ditto over
there.
I have to gain knowledge.
Go anywhere.
I don't care.
Take me to the island.
Ocean fishing can be fun.
You may meet different species than you would in freshwater.
What?
I can fish?
After a fierce training session, Pokemon can rest there.
Oh!
What is this place?
Where am I?
holy shit there's more to this game
oh my god it says evolution wait can i oh is it like i can
have more oh if i build more of it wait is there so much
more to this i didn't even realize there's like other places
oh my god geo dude i guess he shows up here island?
Like the routes and stuff?
There's the matcha.
Matcha.
They only show up here?
Or can I have them?
Or will they show up on my other island?
Beep, beep, beep.
Obtaining information about this town.
Guys, I don't think Ash is a...
Guys.
I have it yet.
I don't know, I don't have a theory, but I think Ash might
be dead.
He's finally no longer 10 anymore.
Oh, what happened in Palant- Ash is Ash now?
Are we Ash's mom did?
Take ashes 10 feet under.
You can freely alter the landscape.
This land belongs to no one.
I can rebuild Palatel.
I'm pretty sure someone's actually going to recreate
Palatel.
Oh.
We could.
Okay.
We either do new Palatel.
town not the new the new palette town or toky town remake it
very it's like new Vegas you know new Las Vegas a new and
new palette does it fit oh
my god keep fucking up like because I use too many different
controllers and keeps fucking with me new new palette wait
we have a better idea i have a better one guys i have a
better name
welcome to power
we can let's see if i can actually put that name uh like do
you think they'll let me do you think do you think i'll be
crazy i've got censored but don't let them i don't know okay
okay okay okay we'll play it safe don't key down
i know like file red started censoring don't key down All
right,
I can't believe it, Palutown.
It's got, I'm no coward.
That's it.
You baited me.
I'm no coward.
So it's figuring out, because I'm pretty sure they're still
in the lawsuit right now.
on is pow world okay yes they've registered at least new pow
world new oh shesh have been like new pow world you're right
pow world too these eminem are ready to help you develop
your their generous prizes for those who complete them so
please give them your best Keep on living your best poke in
life.
We did it.
Oh, I can get a roommate, too.
Now you're right.
Wait, can I change the name?
Rename town.
Let's go.
There we go.
Welcome to Powell World Day.
Yay!
Huh?
Eevee!
A Pokemon?
A Pokemon!
Yep, what's up?
Um, all us hanging out- Oh my god, I don't make her a
Sylveon.
Hang out, my friends, but then when I woke up, I was all by
myself.
I looked everywhere around here.
I really have, but I couldn't find any of them.
Where did everyone go?
like a job for me you're gonna help me thanks what are you
looking for exactly what do they all look like oh my friends
oh there was one who really liked fire and one oh we're
finding the evolutions and one said they really love
electricity and one that could never get enough so you have
a lot of friends beep beep beep in a spot of trouble at
times like this try taking on the special challenge.
If you complete it, you're reselling something you can use
to make a new Pokemon habitat.
That really surprised me.
I didn't think it taught.
I don't really get what I was saying, but you think you can
help me find my friends?
If I wasn't done telling you about them, I can give you more
details.
You know what's surprising?
For how much they milk the evolutions, I'm so surprised they
haven't in new evolutions in a long time like if anything I
feel like making more evolutions would be like easier to
milk you learn about Evie's friends yeah it's been a long
time since Sylvia I wonder what's everyone up to I sure do
miss them because they are the cowards we're missing so many
we're like there's drag there could be dragon ghost uh bug
uh flying uh poison i feel like ghost evolution is gonna be
is it'll be really cool uh let's just adapt what do you want
oh you just want pretty flower bed okay trade you can trade
rock steel you know design is not a story to pursue, but
they are vast and undeveloped, so you can build them up as
you see fit.
You also invite others to play, to help you develop Oh!
You also bring Pokemans from other towns to Palatown.
There are some Pokemans?
Oh!
You mean my pal world, too.
Is that not taking this super chat?
I can't believe it.
We're reap.
What happens to Palatown?
What did What do you mean there's no story in these towns?
Palantown is gone!
You can't say there's no story!
They new to Palantown!
They don't have a story.
It's just gone.
Work together with other players and plan to create fun and
live.
Oh my god I can invite you guys to the PAL world.
Let's look at these beautiful stars.
Oh, I can collect honey here!
Oh!
I have more honey.
Alright, let's go this way.
Oh, there's fire here.
Why?
Is that where... Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, dropped another thing!
Okay.
Oh!
I don't know what to do with these feathers yet, but they're
pretty.
What's up here?
Freezing chamber kit.
What the fuck is that?
Scatter some Pokemon this mixed rose mountain with a...
What?
What does that make?
Oh my god!
I'm building an entire city!
What?
How do I build this?
Oh my god.
This entire area is just gone.
It's just mine now.
It's actually just mine now.
Like, I'm literally...
I'm building...
Oh my god.
I'm building up an entire city, I guess.
What the fuck do I put this in?
I kept my own gated community.
I claimed the bay.
But...
I claimed it under power.
This is now the property of Powell World, too.
Sionara, Link.
All right, I'll dig here.
I like how I got everything but the one area I needed.
Oh, I got shells.
Ah, seaweed.
All right, I guess that's just honey.
We'll just leave the eat.
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
No wonder they're like, don't come to this island.
I don't think you're ready to learn the truth.
Like, oh my god, that's why it's called Wizard.
Bro, this is infinite.
It's adventure time.
It's all right.
I'll come back to the city.
The city will always be there.
They'll always be there.
I don't even have a music player anyway, guys.
and you can't handle okay i gotta figure out how to cross
this without dying come on i can just spam this all right
there you go i was worried about drowning but it's okay
where did i want to is the drift loon still oh he's still
here nice i was like wondering if he's still here or not oh
i didn't see this
oh i got the first aid kit nice team art grunts team rocket
i've decided to give the social media thing a world today is
my first oh that was his first mistake why to bring in new
oh my god it's like the army he's gonna go recruit people at
colleges and has he's gonna make a twitch channel and be
like join team rocket it is great we may not be the heroes
to this story as so as far as most people out there are
concerned to be completely honest we're kind of the villains
but you forget all about the rules and common sense and
stuff we live how we want to live team rockets on twitter
and tick tock it's a psych ops i think that makes i think
that makes us pretty fun organization since we don't have
the best reputation i can't really give out our name but
it's kind of hard to talk about what name so let's go with
team r got it anyway give me a yellow if you're interested
in being a member of team r man i wonder what team is team r
in it was social media as well it killed the talent tab i
like a chill home where i could hang out i'll make you one
you'll make is it because there's no more kids for you to
kidnap is that why are you missing oh wow that's so cool
thank you so much What kind of place you want to live in?
You just want...
Oh, okay.
That's it?
Alright.
That's fine.
It'd be so close I could live close to everyone.
I bet that I'd never be lonely.
That's...
Alright.
Hmm.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Ring, ring, ring.
Okay.
I can't make heads or tails of this PC.
Wait, why do I see real Doki?
What you doing?
Huh?
Well, wait, oh, wait, that's cute.
Wait, you kind of see me too, real Doki?
That is like, which game was it?
Was it Heart, Gold, and Soul?
Which one were they had cell phones where we call each
other?
Communicating with that Pokedex you're carrying.
Hello, I seem to have gotten an act of this PC.
Let's see, what happens if I push?
Call ended.
Seems like I shouldn't go pushing buddhings willy-nilly.
Was it silver and gold?
But, yeah, no, silver and gold also had cell phones.
You be careful out there.
It's where they first had it, and then they took it, and
then they never put it in again.
Until black and white.
Ah!
I got a picnic basket.
Where is...
Oh, there's the mushrooms.
Hey, what?
Who's talking to me?
Somebody, anybody, from beyond the stone?
Oh, I can get a Venom off here.
A mushroom lamp, yeah.
Grab more.
Let's start sucking.
All right, I want to grab this.
Smooth rock.
Okay, where is the Pokemon that called for me?
Hello?
Okay, he lives there.
That's it.
Oh, never mind.
I'll dig here.
I'll dig my way over.
Oh, wait, loot.
How do I dig over there?
I can't smash everything.
What do you mean?
There are places I cannon can't smash what's the point
what's the point if I can't smash everything oh it's an onyx
hello sir hello
I'm sort of stuck but hello hey but I'm glad you find me
sorry but I think you could help me sure thing I need you
too let's scratch each other's back this is kind of
embarrassing but i got myself stuck here normally i could
bore straight through a cave like this no problem out of
here and beyond i'm gonna flash but i guess i overslept and
my muscles still haven't woken up or something because the
walls and floors here are wicked hard i was about to give up
if i'm being honest but look at you bud you made it here
that means you can smash through the walls and floors with
this cave, yeah?
Then you can bust up the wall in front of you to help me get
out of here?
That's a good question.
It rapidly bores through the ground at 50 miles per hour by
squirming and twisting its massive rugged body.
Oh, it has crushed, too.
Stone stuff.
Lots of dirt.
Nice.
Alright, um, let's see because I sort of fucked up too.
whoops oh okay wait dang I thought for sure you could do it
I was heard that you should start using your head when your
muscles don't work but I'm not good at that like a headbutt
but if a headbutt could do a trick I'll be up you know any
really smart Pokemon could you maybe ask them how to bust
through the walls around here I'll be patiently waiting here
I'm counting on oh no maybe professor maybe the professor
knows right he should know I'll bust open this for a sec
could be important later because he said he needs a smart
Pokemon and I don't think any of my Pokemon are smart
including me okay what scad
what oh is that a gym oh that's cool
someone will keep onyx has bulldozed i think like onyx he's
just weak as hell has added what's this oh i'm pretty sure
those pokemans are dead now though That's cute.
That's a really big berry.
I'll grab this.
Oh!
A Rallet clock.
I love Rallet.
Rallet's my favorite in that gen.
Anything up here?
Holy shit, this island is fucking huge.
I feel like I've been...
Every area is a new place.
Boop.
nice clock whoops this is a massive island a mushroom street
light I wish I'm I know how to decorate or terraform or
terraform or like any point of interior design I'm so bad at
it I just don't know how to I'm just not an architect I have
no sense of like architectural design in me.
Oh my god, there's vending machines?
Like, which area is this?
Wait, this is the Pokemon!
We all know that everyone's beloved music streaming services
are being forced to shut down one by one.
Dude, this is getting too real.
This is, yeah, I got a level of my function.
This is why I hire people to decorate for me.
oh no oh no it's like that what was that there was a website
that was that was there for archiving like um discontinued
games or um what are you called the dead like dead games or
whatever and then they had to shut down the website because
they can't afford new like they can't afford um um to pay
for a server cost anymore because of because of ai taking up
making it more and more expensive yeah abandonware yeah
while music lovers are still mourning the loss of these
streaming services it isn't all bad news in the world of
music it's our pleasure to share a little about technical
technological blast from the past compact oh my god cds are
back oh no they're back cool little gadgets used by great
great grandparents to listen to all their fame oh no this
might be like 10 years in the future or something each cd
can hold but that's not all each cd is a one-time purchase
which means there's no need or subscription fee no matter
how many tabs pokemon is working hard to create a solid line
of a seat oh this is not good i got 10 screen oh no this is
getting a little too real turns into dust wait there's
something upstairs see I'm a parkour transform did a oh no I
can't get up there wait unless go did oh i can climb up this
no i can't i can't be bothered i should go back yeah this is
definitely post-apocalyptic there's no way there has to be
like there has to be like a society of humans we all thought
finn the human was the last human guys oh wait i'm actually
carrying too much stuff but he's a survivor there's gotta be
an island of humans i think this game is trying to warn us
something or teach us something uh and teach an alpha
whippersnappers how we old people did things before things
around here uh rim thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i think ai is making us dumber in a way we're like
because there's like there's stuff like vibe coding and um
and uh and also like kids graduate college by just using AI
or high school too and I think like because of that we're
starting to lack critical thinking more and more the amount
of people doing vibe coding is very concerning because it's
a huge security risk like I
think I think like the amount of times people who are doing
vibe coding and it leaks everything it leaks it leaks
everything like everybody's personal
Okay, let's see, I want to...
Same with...
Let's see, yeah.
I never get bored when I'm with you, Ditto.
Here, I want to give you...
Oh, yay!
Do I even have space?
Beans!
I'm gonna put it on the floor.
Thanks for the gift.
All right.
let's see i'm gonna put away the cds because i don't need
that and i don't need the shells i don't need this uh oh i
need the first aid kit to build stuff and i have to like
there's some good good things that it that ai has made more
accessible for people but i think like there are moments
where we might have we are definitely have taken it too far
with ai i think it's like
You know what I mean?
There's some cool things that have been...
Oh my god, why is everyone surrounding my house?
Like...
Act Rock is this real?
Act Rock fact-checked this for me.
I can put all of this away, though.
I don't really almost have enough.
I just don't have enough Pokey Mens.
Okay.
because there are some useful things that ai has given us
but there's also like not useful thing and people just been
taking too much advantage over ai
yeah that's what i mean like it abused in a way where like
it's just like it's so accessible that people have been
taking advantage of it
all right we got that oh yeah we gotta give hitmon a friend.
Or let me...
Blah.
Wait, actually, we don't need this.
Okay, it's like, it feels so lush now, and I took it out.
And Molly was like, oh my god, finally, trees!
And I was like, alright, time to cut it down.
Alright, let's see it.
Let's see.
we need how do i my cat have shit in jokey town who wants to
talk to me oh yeah i knew i talked to the professor okay and
i know make a home for um the child kidnapper but it's okay
there's no children in in withered wasteland oh my god just
realized there was a map i've been covering the map this
entire time i didn't even realize i didn't even notice that
i I've been playing off of I've been playing off of my OBS I
can't see it I was like Oh my god wait Wait a minute You're
table There's a map here Okay he needs a first aid kit A
chair and table Wait do I have?
I should right?
Oh wait my storage is here
Oh Oh the super chat thank you thank you as someone who is
studying hacking ethically it's worse than you think as some
companies literally use ai to build entire back-end servers
it makes this dragon very sad thank you thank you thank you
i think i think like if a developer like a developer that
doesn't actually know how okay like this is one of my things
that i'm like really scared about where a lot of companies
aren't hiring devs anymore and they're just doing vibe
coding where they just like use ai to code majority of
things a lot ai is still learning ai does not know how to
have strong security when it comes to like websites and
that's scary because a lot of websites have been getting
hacked non-stop now because the security is so fucking weak
like it's like the security is so weak now
and i saw like so many instances like where um where
people's information has got leaked because of the because
like websites are being built super poorly all right we
gotta make a large chair i'm not sending our money on new
furniture i'll make it
all right and then okay yeah that's fine they just hit mine
um look this is just my experiment city Power World 2 is
where we as a group together can make it beautiful.
All right.
Let's see.
Yeah, and then vibe coding, they'll be like, um, AI, please
make it more.
Please make the security better.
And you know, they're like, don't worry, we will.
And they never did.
Like,
yeah, there you go.
got you a friend seek first aid immediately pokemon skill at
healing may come to his him i'm pretty sure hitman lee does
not heal wait what this is when injured seek first aid
immediately pokemon skilled at i'm that's i thought that
does not look like chancy to me guys that
Why is this Hitmon Lee?
He gives you combat.
Don't worry.
He'll heal with his fists.
Like, why is that not Chansey?
Why is it just him?
His very gentle kicks.
Urgent care.
Oh, my God.
That's why.
He'll send you.
This is his hand.
habitat because he'll send you he'll send you to the to the
hospital he punches the illness away guys all right so um
drift loom wants to live here um which is a little
concerning i'll put him in the corner here maybe he can live
actually oh that's the cave i made he'll live here he'll
live here he's like the creepy little creepy guy lives in
the cave i know this was for hoot hoot but like i think this
is better i wouldn't yeah i don't think any of us would feel
safe near him but he wants to live with everyone else oh
yeah three fires i need to build three fires that's all he
wants right i keep pressing why because i keep thinking
that's the run button but it's b I don't know, I feel so
used to running with Y.
Yeah, I need three.
Guys, we don't want a child kidnapper near this community.
Guys, we have to put him somewhere safe for all Pokemans.
Alright, here we go.
Boop.
There we go.
And I need Charmander.
Follow.
Charmander.
what's on the other side all right childmander wake up i
need you to like this follow me but there's no child we
don't know yet guys there could be what if what if the one
the human island we don't know that okay we need you to like
this one Last one.
What if we find a human island?
And then, like, the humans come over and be like, oh my god!
Pokemans!
You're all still here!
And then, like, and then this Drift Loom comes over and
kidnaps the kids.
Like, that's gonna make us look bad.
Well, this is Pokeman, dude.
Alright, there we go.
Is he gonna show up?
Where is he?
I don't want Okay, wait You have too much space now I gotta
fix that
Oh, that's fine There you go I think the only issue I have
with this game It's just so hard to Craft this property
Where's the drift boom Oh
like where is he
where is he I made you your home where are you
oh I have to talk to him I forgot okay alright I gotta talk
to him be like I got you your house now cut oh yeah you can
leave go go You can leave now.
Suck.
Alright, let's go find...
Wait, just hit him on.
Hit him on, he's still not here.
Alright, let's talk to the child kidnapper.
Oh, I actually need these rocks, too.
Oh.
Suck.
Hello!
Oh my god, has it really been four hours?
Oh, I've been...
having a lot of fun this is really like what in this all
right there you go you like your new house
you like it you have to be live in the cave though because
you make the rest of the residents very uncomfortable i
don't know if he likes it uh no humans huh no why did you
say that Oh no, he's scared.
He has that urge in him right now.
He's like, he has the itch.
He's like, oh man, remember the good old days when I could
just kidnap a child whenever I want.
Like, I just bring him up and...
What an odd thing to say.
Like...
He's relapsing.
the yoyink he wants to talk why thanks for making me home I
only want to take you so but aren't we running humans around
here are there to like human
to like humans because I don't think it's no guys i don't
think he was joking anymore
so he wants me to take he wants to take me somewhere and he
not really helping with the allegations he needs to tell his
neighbors he's on on a lid
It's real.
Don't go to his island, Toki.
This is why he lives in a game.
You guys were like, don't treat.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Who are the drift loon defenders?
Come on.
Where's your excuse now?
Where's...
What excuse do you have for him now?
with all the people who were saying I was so cruel for
putting him in a cave what about them I don't know I just
really don't feel like doing anything at all
yeah I oh no no I do not I I do not no I'm not you I was not
I was not in any emails I do your best at it always like you
get me right you and I were the same look I didn't think
it'd be this no we are not the same wow you're pretty you
know gung-ho about things aren't you that perked me up a
little bit thanks you know even if the humans I bet I could
get a kick of energy from, you know, dolls that humans were
really attached to.
Now that I think about it, I'm getting a doll vibe from over
that way.
So, baby, check it out.
You know, do you find the doll?
You should come show it to me.
No, don't talk to him.
Do not talk to him.
Leave.
Do not look at him.
He is in the cave for a reason.
We need to pop that balloon stat.
Hey, diddle.
I just want to say thanks for all the proof you and me.
Oh, nice.
I got some run Charmander.
But I think we need to close that cave.
I, I, I,
I did not think, I did not think it would go that far.
We gotta steal the cave.
What's on the other side?
Oh, real Doki, do you have a moment?
I can't, why is he in the cave?
He know what he's done.
What if Drew, I'm like, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't stop wondering, what's beyond that wall of stuff?
own.
I don't believe that wall was back there when I was there
back when I was a young little thing.
But whether it existed then or not, so much time has passed
that I don't remember at all what lies beyond it.
Seeing what you're capable of now, I dare say you could
break through that wall for me.
Could you please take me to the other side of the wall?
Do you have a question for me?
But I would like to see the other side of the wall first.
I'm just too preoccupied with that to think about anything
else alright let's let's break that ball guys oh man oh man
guys I think it was a mistake to introduce him in our
community we should have not brought him back home oh they
come across in a shop or anywhere else you should get it
while you have the chance get meta oh my god i thought he'd
be different i thought you know i thought it was just a joke
i thought it was just a rumor it was not a rumor guys
they're all real every conspiracy theory theory you have
it's actually real
Oh, well, will you look at that?
So this is what waited us on the other side.
Now that I see it again, I do have some faint memories of
gazing out over the sea as a child.
Hmm?
Oh, do you see the magic harp?
What could this be?
It's covered in sand, but certainly looks like a human-made
building of some sort.
I don't think they used to be here in the old days either.
it was in the but they rewrote it they took it out of the
polka dex so i was like oh maybe don't you they took it out
they paid the they paid the scientists off to take it out of
the polka dex they redacted it i don't think they used to be
here in the old days either what's that box do hickey the
right the the Pope festers were paid off and the cover-up
goes deeper than you think all right what is this
oh is this really a recording uh whatever i'll give it a go
the box spoke is this another pc excuse me you there welcome
to your hide-up you look like a real hero and you know a
real nice guy but wait whoever hears this might not be a guy
forget that last part you're a I mean you have honest
looking eyes I'm certain you're a pure and worthy heart all
of us have a pure and worthy heart to see what after all
we're a business that use Pokemon or I mean it's Team R
we're an organization that works hard to improve the
environment for the sake oh my God, it goes deeper than you
think.
Oh my God, it's the deep state.
It's all connected.
Team R, Team Rocket had something to do with this.
The Pokemon League is probably involved, too.
I mean, we're an organization that works hard to improve the
environment for the sake of all Pokemon.
The deep Pokemon state.
independent.
That look in your eyes told me like you don't want to join,
right?
Well, I can tell you got a lot of potential to protect the
world from devastation.
So that was a lie, wasn't it?
She was like, just in love.
Meow, that's right.
But if you really want to become one of us, you have to
overcome a difficult trial.
We call it the team initiation challenge.
Let's get you started right away with part one.
All right.
Oh, I have that.
Your first task is to gather berries and put, wake up, I'm
doing a challenge.
And put them in this delivery hatch.
Don't worry, we're not going to eat them.
They're for Pokemon, of course.
And one more thing.
As you work your way, through the team initiation challenge
you'll get some quality gifts we'll be waiting with bated
breath get to it seems like it's finally done talking
couldn't make heads or tails what it was saying but it
sounded like a human voice and they seem like they might
need help i'm really curious about about this building it
might even give us some clues about what happened to the
humans but there's no use standing here thinking about it do
you mind stopping by from time to time check on this
building though just once in a while would be fine all right
important requests underway all right time to put the
barrier in oh yeah I did I have an onyx stuck there and onyx
is stuck in a cave dear me I certainly hope we can do
something to help there's first things thirst let's head
back and discuss this with others all right let's put the
berries in oh submit testing well look like you've already
cleared part one of the team initiation challenge you're
even more impressive than I thought no doubt You'll zoom up
the ranks once you join our organization.
As promised, here's a fabulous gift for your efforts.
Yay!
Oh, I got a bouldery badge?
That's a pretty snazzy badge, eh?
Just hold it.
It makes me feel like your Pokemon.
It makes you feel like your Pokemon are a little stronger,
doesn't it?
Anyway, part two.
Beans, tomatoes, and wheat.
Part two is all about vegetables.
We got this, hot shot.
Oh, you got this.
I have beans.
I just don't know where to find tomatoes yet.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Brock's children will live on for him.
Brock's siblings and kids.
Oh my god, they got him.
Team Rockets got him.
Wait, where's my slowpoke?
He still hasn't spawned yet.
Is it because he doesn't want to live next to Magikarp?
Is that why?
I don't want it.
How's your comfort level?
Oh, it's kind of nice.
He said kind of nice.
Where is the...
Okay, he said he wanted dogs.
But where is the dogs?
Wait, how do I break?
Come on.
I don't know how to break it.
Wait, I must say...
That's it?
That...
Oh, yeah, wait until he's next to everyone.
Okay, he's gonna ask everyone here.
Alright, that's gonna sit.
Where?
How is he gathering?
He is not gathering the others.
Hey, did you know?
Wait, where did the worst balloon boy?
Oh, wait!
Hey, Mon Lee is here!
Oh, Christelle down.
He's here!
Hiya!
Oh, you all right there?
Sure, I'm sorry if I started you.
I'm always practicing my kicks every chance I get.
Watch yourself when walking through this area.
Hello!
Whoa!
Oh my god, thank god there was a med kit.
left here.
And a high kick.
Yes, indeed.
My kicks are snappy again today.
Ha, ha, ha.
All right.
Get in my Pokédex.
Let me scan you.
He has complete control over the ligaments and slugs,
expanding and contracting them to double the reach of its
kick.
He has urgent care.
Trade.
What the fuck?
Why?
All they know how to do is trade.
What am I supposed to do?
to at the cash register wait i'm gonna i'm gonna make them
work minimum wage jobs i'm gonna i'm gonna make them i'm
gonna make them work at a combini
you burn a recipe as a reward for discovering lots of
pokemans i'm recreating society
You got a recipe for a wooden plate.
Nice.
This is getting too real.
I was just like, I was like so confused.
I was like, what are these cash registers?
Like, what is the trading thing?
And then he's a cashier.
Oh my god.
He worked so hard being a martial artist and now he's
regulated it to be a cashier.
All those years of training.
No, he can't even be a Hollywood star Because we This We're
inventing capitalism for Pokemon Because we destroyed
Palatown His education His degree is useless A martial
artist Can't pay bills Oh my god Poor hitman Me Poor Hitman
Lee.
We invented cap.
We're going to invent capitalism.
The humans might have destroyed the world.
But capitalism never dies.
Capitalism never dies.
So me lots.
So completed that.
I remember, how do I increase my environment again?
Nice.
Oh, if they're...
Oh, yeah, they're...
Yeah, I have to be more comfortable.
Did a reinvented capitalism.
Hello, everybody.
Could get around here for a moment.
Oh, are we all working together to dig on Excel?
I'm a martial...
I can does...
It does a fairly poor job at paying bills.
Gam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's up, Professor?
Oh.
What belts are you?
Which martial art did you learn?
What belt did you get?
Are you a black belt?
It seems that Onyx is trapped in the cave.
Thank you, Mr. Chapp.
Thank you.
And the walls of said caves are so hard.
Even real Doki can't break through them.
Does anyone have any great brainstorms about what we can do
to help?
If we're dealing with super solid ground, we could try
spraying it with some water.
We'd add and make it all squishy and soft.
hmm the walls i don't think onyx can float guys guys let
onyx guys i don't think like i don't think his body is made
of helium guys i'm pretty sure he'd be dropping onyx into
the water he's gonna fucking sink in the water like just
sink to the bottom of the ocean and he's gonna find the uh
yeah he's weak by the way he's also weak to water they will
drown the onyx like what was wait wasn't it in one of the
mu2 movies they made a pokemon that wasn't supposed to learn
know how to swim swim in water which one was it was it the
mu2 movie that um that one of like they chucked a random
pokemon in there that should not be able to swim um if the
walls are so hard that even tough one like onyx can't deal
with them i imagine it would take more than a little water
to soften them up that's then why don't we just wait for it
to to rain
hmm rain you say why not can swim that's crazy i even know
that you can learn swim what does it sound true oh my god i
just remember i was like why is that swimming like every
other trainer threw like water Pokemon and the one not and
then this one guy threw a non water Pokemon everyone's like
what the fuck and they're like Gyarados Lapras Magikarp and
then Tentacruel and then this guy threw a non water type
into the fucking ocean but it doesn't really rain around
these pines.
How come?
I couldn't tell you why, but last time I...
It doesn't rain anymore.
What did we do?
Where's Kai Ogre?
They killed Kai Ogre.
Grydon did it.
He won.
He killed Kai Ogre.
I saw any rain Bob was when I was just back when there was
still humans around here.
I haven't seen so much as a drop.
What the fuck happened?
What happened in this universe?
I finally got the fish.
Rekwaza didn't stop him at the time.
Team Magma did it.
No rain, no pain.
Hold on.
What do you mean, no rain?
We need rain.
Oh my god, like a squirrel.
What do you need?
Charmander, magma.
Apologies.
I'm sure a little rain could not only help Onyx, it might
cheer up the other Pokemon here as well.
Sounds good.
Let's make it rain.
Easier said than done, I'm afraid.
Let's see.
How can we get it to rain?
We're gonna learn to rain down.
well there's even stuff you don't know professor like this
is actually the bad ending we're in the bad timeline right
now what does rain bring to mind i think i got it we need a
slow poke slow poke yes if we have certain pokemon called
slow poke helping us we might be able to make it rain do you
think you could find a slow poke and bring him here if i
were called directly, Slowpoke likes sleeping in a tall
grass near the sea.
Do you recall the sandcover building we found beyond the
rock wall that you broke?
If there's any tall grass around, I'm sorry, Slowpoke would
like it.
Oh, that's why he hasn't spawned yet.
What was the Slowpoke lore?
No, they're like, they're like doing a lot of callbacks and
references and everything in this game.
It's crazy.
There's so many, like, Easter eggs and callbacks to, like,
to, like, the anime and the show and the manga.
After the rediscovering capitalism, re-rediscovered making
it rain.
Aina, they give the super chat, they give thank you.
Yeah, it's actually a post-apocalyptic rebuilding sim.
All right, let's go.
When they yawn, they make rain.
Wait, is that true?
oh my god he's in this cave right now he's he's just staring
it he's just staring in the cave he's so creepy guys he's so
creepy he's so creepy close the cave he's staring into to
the... Oh, there he is.
He showed up.
That's why he wasn't showing up.
I thought it was the Magikarp.
I just didn't want to live next to him.
You have to do something about the menace.
Um, do I know you?
Oh, are we friends?
Maybe.
Uh, maybe not.
Uh, well, nice to meet you.
Hey, y'all, snowpuck!
It's incredibly slow and dopey.
It takes five seconds for it to feel pain when under attack.
Jesus Christ, man.
He likes to yawn.
Okay, he's like a planner.
Alright, follow me.
Away there.
Follow me.
me your man oh hey there okay i gotta actually talk to you
come with me come with me oh so i have the power to make it
right oh i guess i do god he's rich cool oh but hold on the
grounds around here right it's hard to walk i think i'm
gonna get up you know tied up before we even make it to the
professor not that kind of rain bro he plays steps where the
terrain is different heights pokemon will be able to walk
more easily So Pokemon can walk much further on moisten
paths than on dried up ground.
All right, I gotta make ladders for him.
Kino, clear off the path and make it easier to walk on.
That'd be great, because, uh, oh right, because I want to
get to the professor.
All right, replacing steps, you encourage Pokemon to travel
further.
When Pokemon, they can visit buildings such as Pokemon
centers or other people's homes.
All right, how do I?
Okay, I gotta make this nicer for this.
Yo, diddo.
Yeah?
I just kinda...
Here's...
Oh, yay!
Free stub!
Phoenix, thank you for the super st- Oh, it's just a fucking
stick, okay?
I'm gonna make the stairs.
That's why they have this.
I have enough?
Oh my god, I need lumber.
I used it all up earlier.
Here we are.
Okay, I remember there was lumber here.
want to start like uh oh my god i want i don't want to start
cutting up trees right now i got me more stairs though i can
just farm the fallen trees here oh no oh no they're just
gonna drown okay there you go i should be fine here suck all
right i'm just gonna don't worry I'll spam my jump
Suck Alright this way
And then we're gonna go Make that stairs Wait was that not
lumber?
Was that just Oh my god that was just sticks That was just
sticks It was never lumber I didn't even realize I thought
those were sticks
what wait then wait how do i make lumber is it this
wait what also lose
oh i have to give them the site there okay
just hijack that's true i could lose no because like Let's
just make it for now.
It's being a little bitch right now.
Alright, Scyther, can you...
Oh, he's...
Oh, I gotta say, he's guarding the cave.
Oh, I have that.
It's your thing.
Make my logs.
Alright, you ready?
Score, bada-bomb.
This will take me a while.
Wait, when is he...
Oh, my God.
Look at him.
He's so cool.
Hold on.
Just, heya!
Oh my god, there we go.
Ma'am, go back in your house.
Go back in your house.
Go back, go back in your house.
Oh shit, I thought he like got me.
I thought he got me there.
Got scared.
I thought he was about to kidnap me.
Yeah, he's going at it.
He's going wild with that.
I can water this, actually.
And then we'll get another Pokemans.
How long does it take?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I might as well.
Alright, apparently he lives here.
Alright, we're gonna do something wild.
I think it's time.
I think it's time to grab the dolls.
It's this way.
It's one log site, exactly!
Wait, is that Diglet?
Oh, no, it's Trilbert.
Phew.
Still around here is a little crumbly, huh?
Oh, hey, nice to meet you.
Do you live around here?
I don't really know a whole lot about this area, so...
Yeah, I showed me the ropes, okay?
Trilbert, my goat.
My pudding...
Oh, he has search!
Wait, we need that.
Trying to get better at using rototiller.
A little bit of a pickle.
I wish I'd mean the soil around here is so dry.
It's straight up crumbled when I try to till it.
All right, you want me to water this?
If only there was someone who was the nicest person ever and
could water the dry soil around here for me.
Oh, man, who could do that, I wonder?
Hmm.
Want to slip me something nice before I, you know...
You know, you want me to do it for free or, you know, maybe
a little incentive there.
Oh, now the soil looks super nice and soft.
And all thanks to you.
Thank you so much.
Time to get my Dylan on.
So watch and learn if you want.
Here I go.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, I can dig.
too oh my god look at my hands i i think it'd be cute it was
sand i wish it was like sand shrew i like sand shrew more
than drillbert rototiller or diglet whoa you did it i guess
because like they didn't know what to i was like but what
you do if you got diglet's powers you turn into like you're
just a head on the ground like
You're pretty good at this.
After you tell the soil, you can...
Oh, I can make farms now.
I wish I had a place to live.
Okay, what do you want?
Yeah, Diglet doesn't have hands.
Yeah, I could just be a head on the ground.
Alright, you want all peas.
He just wants peas.
Is that literally it?
You just want all peas?
Like...
these parts don't seem to call him a veggie feels for me to
live in but you look like a type of trainer who can make it
happen so take these i mean i'll just you'll just live here
go ahead and use those seats to make a home for me give it a
go uh you don't have enough seats you can buy them at the pc
shop i just want to dig this though wait can i dig this to
grab items no i actually have to punch this this oh nice cd
a damn damn did all right 20 blocks wait how much inventory
i don't can only carry one more so we gotta we gotta find
the doll okay found a door though that's almost like the
doll improving your quality of life has been added maintain
a coverable life level of brightness and temperature in your
house don't hold back when you want something decorate your
home live where it's easy to take walks.
Am I at...
Oh.
Yeah, arrive in the area gate.
Please place your Pokedex over the gate panel.
Oh, can I unlock this now?
Oh, never mind.
I'm too low level.
I'm still a baby.
Hello?
Can you hear me real jokey?
Whereabouts are you now?
Oh, that looks like the gate right hmm as far as i could
recall the only folks who were able to get through the gate
back in the day were humans known as professors or trainers
you look like a trainer yourself you know so you may be able
to pass through there at some point well not yet i'm too
weak is it the badges i wonder i wonder if it's the badges
okay apparently the dolls live here I gotta figure out where
the fuck the dolls are.
The legendary ninja family.
Oh!
The region in question was once inhabited by a famous clan
of ninjas.
Koga, Fuchsia, city gym leader was in the distant past.
His daughter, Janine, were both members of this clan.
Oh my god, I'm a ninja!
Wait, what?
I like my other outfit, though, the distant past.
Oh, my God.
I don't know.
I like my other outfit more, to be fair.
I learned ninja.
I learned the way of the ninja.
I think this is cuter.
Like, what do you mean, distant past?
Yeah.
No, it resets the color, too.
Yes.
I want, yeah.
I like this outfit more.
I like how the hat looks like an egg yolk.
And that's cute.
Trying to find the fucking...
The fucking doll.
The creepy doll that the Drift Loom wants.
Yeah, I'm the Hokage.
Oh, nice.
I got roses.
Maybe it's over there.
I think it's on the other side.
All right, we gotta actually get rid of some of these
things, though.
You missed the lumber?
We don't need lumber.
Not yet.
Oh my gosh, okay, wait.
Maybe...
I'll come back later for it.
I'm parkouring right now.
Oh, hey.
Put away.
Swallow that.
This year's top trend.
Undercuts and half-updues are yesterday's news.
This year's top trend is the center part.
A hugely famous influencer recently posted a selfie with a
new parted hairstyle, and fans are going wild.
Which influencer are they talking about?
Oh!
Wait, who?
Who?
Oh, no.
Yeah, I mean, influencers have been...
part of the Pokemon games for a while.
We have like, like, the newest one actually has a streamer
now.
I'm like, who the fuck has this hairstyle?
I don't fucking recognize that.
Literally, who?
Who is this guy?
Oh, I can't go any further.
I was gonna say, it looks like they're gonna get me.
I'm gonna become one with the mist.
It felt very ghost-like there.
I thought it was something.
Wait, is there something underneath that?
Right?
There is.
Why did I miss that?
Oh, I'm carrying too...
God damn, I'm carrying too much.
Oh, shit.
I didn't want to take a picture.
Okay, I need to put this somewhere.
Alright, I gotta go back down.
I wanted to find the creepy dog!
Where the fuck is the creepy doll?
Alright, we're gonna go down.
You must have finished my logs now, right?
Oh, they're having so much fun.
Oh, there's more stuff.
Okay, wait.
I gotta put some stuff away, guys.
I have too much stuff.
We'll talk later.
Um, we're getting rid of the CD.
uh i don't think i need more of this we're putting that away
or getting rid of the roses um i'll get rid of that don't
need the side don't need the poke metal what am i to do with
this badge yeah there's another pokemans here too but i'm
gonna put away some stuff first
all right
Who's the new new friend That's okay Oh my god Drift Bloom
is like Don't get out of here Oh it's a combi He's the Drift
Bloom is like Huh is it a child?
Hi there Nice to meet you Are you the one who made this
pretty flower man?
Wow I didn't like that the Drift Bloom was watching that
They get the super chat.
They get the...
It's a lady, too.
Since this is a post-apocalyptic and post-humans, you think
Ditto can actually change into...
If I were a trainer, I'd make Ditto.
Oh, yeah.
They get this...
Oh, I mean, we don't know if his trainer is still alive.
These flowers look like they're really sweet and juicy,
delicious nectar.
We're going to live here now, okay?
Thanks.
See you around.
The trio is together from birth.
It constantly gathers nectar from flowers to please...
the vespi queen oh my god he's gonna become a vespi queen
litter oh okay i was gonna say you come here to litter in my
gated community like excuse me what do you mean litter oh
yeah give me the logs sorry sorry to keep you waiting all
right five pieces actually i figured you could use those to
make tools or furniture or whatever since you're always
making stuff and want to make lumber and don't forget there
are a bunch of pokemon there besides me who can process
material for you to use i'm sure it'd be worth your time to
get to know all kinds of different folks okay i need you to
process more um look at this please keep processing wait no
watch that's mine okay wait thing is i love flowers but then
i try to pick this nasty looking my slice in the shreds yeah
i can get you some flowers and then we're planting somewhere
and give them away as presents okay i still need you uh look
at this there you are i need you to cut this make me some
lumber i'll do 10 i'm way too 50 lumber yes yes holy shit
that's right this is mine
Hey, did you know?
It's literally my, what's it called?
My smelter.
My refinery.
So we gotta...
Okay, now we should be able to...
We should be able to...
Make the stupid steps for him.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Alright, it's this way.
I already forgot where it is.
He's my little forge.
Can you get late happy birth...
Wait, why is he doing here?
Where's I?
Running away.
We had like happy birthday from yesterday.
Possible.
Dokey did love watching streams.
Of course you can.
No.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
No.
Happy birthday to you.
Yay.
Happy birthday.
Oh my god.
I made 10 sets of all.
Oh, I don't think I need a 10.
I.
Oh, all right.
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where is the...
Okay, there he is.
I was going to say, whoops.
May 10.
And, um...
Put that here.
And then...
Here.
All right.
Can you walk now?
How did you get over here?
all right swallow that up all right come with me sure is i
guess i better go check it out then all right here you go
what the fuck what is he doing all the way here
that's your comfort level why did he go all the way here
like i don't understand why he traveled all the way here Oh
my god, I can't even...
He's scripted, guys.
That's so fucked up.
He's actually scripted.
It's kind of hard to walk here.
What do you mean?
What?
He's like, yay!
Oh my god.
He wants actual roads.
I don't know how to make that.
Wait.
okay okay that's wet okay that doesn't that's okay he's
happy is this okay there you go all right i just gotta make
sure this road has liquids on it bro wants this to be like
fucking made of gold.
He wants to be treated like a king.
Oh shit.
Okay, wait.
I forgot, but
oh, please.
Wait, let me get rid of this.
Alright, he's gonna walk this way anyway.
That's why he evolves the slow king.
Okay.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
This is going to take forever.
Why did you walk this way?
There's a road.
Oh, what do you mean dead end?
Oh, no.
Oh.
What do you want?
What do you mean?
That's her's home.
They live here.
What do you mean?
I'm not going to...
There's no way.
there's no way I will brute force this pathway I will not
destroy destroy this community because you don't want to
walk the actual path like are he actually was like destroy
their homes like he actually wanted me to bulldoze oh my got
there's no way you're grouchy.
The pathway is right here.
There is no way you're mad right now.
What is this AI script?
What is this pathway?
I'm so hungry now.
I eat a berry.
Okay, there we go.
We made it.
The needs of the few.
True royalty.
He was red.
He was like take it all down it's in the way bring it all
down oh yeah I wanted to put a security camera right here
oh just just to make sure it's like I made it all right
let's go we have to make sure to keep we have to keep the
community safe hi uh i'm here now oh it's a slow poke thank
you for coming
now then as for why i've asked you here it's because of an
old urban human legend that rain falls when a snow poke
yawns at least that's what i've heard whoa oh my god just
realized he has white hair like he's old because like
normally like tangela they don't show that is that true
awesome i don't know is it true to cut to the chase though
poke could you please yarn for us
i'm really sleepy right now oh uh right um but did you both
ski try for us please it would be such a huge help yes try
men are going to be okay okay I'll give it a shot.
Oh.
Did it work?
Um, um, it's not raining.
I should have figured it wouldn't work.
No, no.
It's just because that yon was only 55 points.
Well, but 55 points?
What are you talking about?
That just now wasn't a serious yon at all.
55 point yon what for me it actually straight to ash to
start raining we need snowpoke to give us a full 100 point
yon probably what the fuck oh wow what the fuck is he
talking about making stuff up so how are we going to give
waffle 100 point nine then hmm well maybe if it was more
humid around here did i be extra i'm not taking i'm not
escorting this guy back and then i get real sleepy humid
they're so dry around here like it's missing some proper
human god that guy this guy is so entitled yeah i forgot i
get that you you do right then let's all work together to
raise the this place and then we'll make it rain yeah what
the fuck how the fuck am i supposed to make it rain make the
humidity god i hate him i hate this pokemon why don't you
start by spraying some water that helps to help the notebook
yon better oh my god okay with the snow okay i gotta
more how much does he have yawn for me slowpoke give me a
yawn oh 56 astra see if they have any ideas okay bro what
the fuck do you have any idea how so I'm I spin my vines
round and round.
Alright, you know what?
Yeah, fuck the rain.
Let's play jump rope.
Oh, I played...
It always felt so nice.
It kind of looked like this.
What?
I thought we were playing jump rope.
Oh my god, that's a lot of flowers.
Alright.
I think we have a really big flower field.
The air would get more humid too.
Take a little while, girl, after you plant.
and but you bring me along i can make him grow instantly
okay we got flowers no i won't play jump rope bobasaur let's
play jump rope let's do it it's mario time it's mario party
time oh my god wait what the fuck it's actually jump rope
guys guys that's practice that's practice guys that's that's
guys guys guys i'm playing through my OBS, guys.
I'm playing...
Guys, rematch.
Yes, yes.
No, no.
Rematch, rematch, rematch.
No, no, wait, wait, rematch.
Get back here.
Wait, wait.
Stop.
Stop walking away.
Okay, let's play jump, bro.
I got this, guys.
Watch this.
I know the pattern now.
Guys, it's a lot slow okay look look it was it was because
like it's because the game was so slow you know it's just
he's not doing it right okay okay here we go i figured it
out i figured it out it's just so slow it's not my fault
okay okay you know that's an improvement that's i double my
score in fact some would say it's triple my score way to go
yay new personal record that's the most you ever met yay it
sure is bobasaur no it's okay I proved I proved to everyone
that I can jump yeah I got a minute once you can answer it
sure what's the quiz What's Onyx's least favorite flavor?
Oh, I...
Spicy?
What?
Oh my god.
I don't fucking know.
This guy's stuck in the cave.
Like, he's stuck in...
Oh my god.
He's stuck in the fucking cave.
So cool.
Yeah, you want to live there?
Thank you so much.
Look, guys.
I have a roommate now.
Oh, he's trying to go home.
Fake Onyx Pat.
Bro, the guy is stuck in a goddamn cave.
I have not interacted with him.
Like, since then.
Okay.
What's his yon level, you think, after that?
I am watering, like, grass.
it's like higher, you know?
I'll just water like all the grasses and the flowers.
Oh my god, he's coming back.
Wait, I can do this here.
I'm watering the trees too.
Okay, I actually really need more fruit though.
I've been eating all my berries all right what is it like no
i'm talking about ray the water kind of gushes out of walls
and stuff there's spring water flow and pull up will make
stuff you know real soggy the air used to be so dry but it's
now getting all nice and human thanks to you all right
what's the humidity now give me a yarn oh my god we're
almost there we're at 60 i told you guys i just spray on the
plants that's the strat yeah because i spray on this
actually need more plants too i need more berries
all right all right we have i'm gonna go up to that area
because i need to find the doll oh wait Oh, he made honey!
The Colby made honey!
Hey, five points is five points, guys.
You gotta take what you can get.
Okay, so, like, the creepy doll is supposed to be here.
Like, that's what...
That's what they said.
That's what Drift Loom said.
He said the creepy doll lives here.
Oh, my God.
Too many people that...
for this.
I remember.
Maybe he lives up on the like on high ground.
Look, if he has the dolls, then like it'd be better for us
as a society.
Guys, think about it.
Okay.
Uh...
For our community, it would be more ideal if he has the
dolls.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot about that fountain.
Yeah, but I want to grab this.
Oh, it's a reef.
Where the fuck is this creepy-ass doll?
I just got this weird feeling when I was at the...
A parasit was acting restless, so I asked it to dig here.
With that, Caroline smiled and showed us...
Oh, a fossil!
Ah, I can point here to communicate with people now.
Nice.
Okay, but where is the creepy doll?
Maybe it's...
in here oh there you go is it this a mysterious slay okay
it's not that oh hey flowers okay we actually need this oh
yeah this is uh okay we don't actually don't mean then water
this 61% I take those yeah but where are the dogs they want
us to find a dog but I can't find a single dog I'm
gonna take these I'm gonna take this oh give me the flowers
I'm yam yam yam yam oh shit I'm yam yam eat them I opened
the spring I'm still trying to find wherever the fuck the
doll is that he wanted I
thought I opened this really but I guess not
oops stop celebrating stop I'm trying to all right bam
Alright, that should raise the humidity a bit.
I'm gonna talk back to the balloon.
Maybe the balloon.
Maybe Drift Loon knows where it is.
Like, oh wait.
Oh my god, I swear to God.
It was just in there.
I swear to God.
Oh my god, there it is.
And what's...
If you set this down, he's gonna take me into Dream Island.
Is that what they're calling it now?
Is that?
Alright.
It's time to go to Dream Island.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he's right here.
There you go.
What do you need again?
Wait, I got you the gloves, right?
Oh, do I have to, like, show it to him?
I'm picking up on, like...
Oh, yeah, there you are.
Okay.
All right, let me...
Oh.
They're so cute.
I bet someone really loved this.
I can feel all the memories that I still...
Oh, my.
Calm down.
Hee-hee-hee-hee.
Oh, ho-ho-ho.
Give me that NGG idea.
How about I take you somewhere amazing right now?
Come on.
Let's go together.
there a mysterious worlds of their own you can collect a
variety exactly what you find will change your magic
depending on what sort of doll you showed a drift balloon
but you can only go to one of these places per day if you
want to go to another dream island yeah try asking him
tomorrow all right i want to go to dream island
Sure.
It's fine.
Take me to Dream Island.
Um.
Oh my god.
That's how they do it.
That's how they did it back then.
Now you're on the...
Let me know when you want to head back.
I'll be chilling.
It'll take us long.
Oh my god.
Somebody's can only be found.
So explore them when you're ready, just talk to Drift Loom.
You can only travel to one dream island.
But you can revisit the island as many times as you want.
If you like to go...
You'll have to wait until the next day.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's an island.
Oh, oh, it's Stardust.
Stardust pieces.
Come on from other people's worlds.
Yeah, it's just music.
Can give me gifts.
Oh.
So I can, like, grab other people's, like, Pokemon.
I can have, like...
I wonder how they would visit my town, though.
I assume, like...
I assume if you're friends or something?
Maybe?
Yeah, that's how you can grab other people's Pokemans.
Wait, do I have enough?
Yeah, I should have put some stuff away.
I'm gonna steal their fucking plants, too.
I'm just curious how, like, how it...
It's supposed to work, you know, like...
Because they're supposed to come from your town, right?
Or, like, from your friend's town or other people's town?
So, like...
I'm just still all the flowers.
I'm not planning shit.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna...
What's the word?
Take their natural resources.
I've half expected the lavender talent that you to play
after he took you to the dream.
Then give him the super chat.
On your thank you, thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Time to plunge, pillage, and plunder.
Oh, my.
Got it.
Natural flowers are a very coveted resource.
Yoink.
That's right.
Bum-bum-bum-bum.
Give me.
That's right.
Taking all your natural resources.
Oh my god.
Does that give me two?
Oh wait, no.
It's just building it up.
It's just a streak going on.
Alright, we're going to grab this.
Because I need more fruit anyway.
Oh, that's so...
many flowers.
Wait, how much?
I don't want to take a picture.
I need to know.
Oh my god, I have 16.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
Okay, that's what...
Oh yeah, I need mines, you're right.
I'll do... I'll cut up that.
Two more.
I wish this was faster, though.
You're right, I gotta cut this up.
Alright, let's cut up the vines.
Oh.
Mine!
Mine.
Take it off.
I found this island first.
I claim it under dokeybird.
Wait, there's a house there.
Wait, there's, that's not a lepa berry.
That's a peach.
Okay.
That's a pent-up area.
We'll lose here.
Why did this not get nuked?
Information, boy.
I'm gonna steal your chair on your table.
Wait, I need more furniture.
How much inventory?
Yeah, I have enough.
Give me your chair.
I'm gonna steal it.
They're all dead anyway.
Is it really stealing if they're all dead?
Guys, think about it.
It's not stealing if they are not alive anymore.
I claim this island house five feet away.
Yes, but they're not alive, so I can still claim it.
I can cut this tree down and then take the seeds.
It should be, like, seeds, right?
Oh, there it is.
Suck.
Yum, yum, yum.
Yeah, there we go.
I got the seed.
What do I...
Oh, I have too many things in my inventory.
I don't...
I think that's everything I need off of this island.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's cut these vines.
Yeah, I can come back to it.
I'll come back later.
Wait, that's a gold.
What is that?
Whose habitat?
What?
It's gold.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
It's common.
What the fuck?
This guy's living in luxury.
Welcoming resort.
Wait, is it Pikachu?
No, is that?
I don't know.
It has an electricity.
I don't know what Pokemon that's supposed to go to.
Wait, there's...
Because I'm like, what the fuck?
Why is this...
Oh, is it Electra Buzz?
It was like...
Look up.
Look up where?
There's nothing to look up.
Wait, there's a tower!
Oh my god, there was something to look up.
Wait, wait.
It's like, what do you mean, guys?
Camers never look up, of course.
It's our way of life.
If we look up, the world will end.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I keep pressing B for some reason.
I don't know why.
Just an instinct.
Oh, one reef.
Oh.
Okay, we gotta...
We don't need a blue.
Oh, wait, actually, maybe we do.
Maybe blue flowers are special.
I don't know what to get rid of.
It may be...
Okay, we're gonna...
I just wanna know what this is.
Oh, my God.
It's a fucking sign.
It's just a fucking sign.
Wait, there's an important...
Probably.
We don't... We can't even read.
Oh my god, I could take this ladder.
Okay, that's five.
What's this?
A garden table!
Wait, I want to take their ladder.
Maybe I can construct it.
Pick it up No, pick up the ladder
Yoink Alright, we don't need blue flowers Yeah, we don't
need blue flowers
Ignore them, eat the ladder It's okay, I got two ladders No
The carrot's going to be important.
I'm going to take it with me to Powell World 2.
No, I took the red Pokeball.
It gave me... The red Pokeball was literally at this.
The garden table.
Alright, don't worry.
I want to go back.
There is a cast form.
What?
Where was he?
It's okay.
He's...
Also, Drift Luna is practicing.
Yeah!
Alright, yawn for me.
Battle of the Springs.
Maybe we put a fountain near one, then the water could
splash around?
A good idea.
Oh my god.
He's so demanding.
Give me a yawn.
Oh my god, we're almost there, alright.
Alright, let's grab this.
Yeah, we're completing a lot.
Alright, there's the grass, there's...
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
Oh, I knew I was gonna play more, but I have two streams
around.
That was really... Oh, I just realized.
I just...
You can never...
avoid it you can never run away oh there's more i didn't see
that oh but it was fun so far i could yeah i definitely time
passed by super fast i can't believe it's almost six hours
time really passed by so fast but i've been having a lot of
fun i definitely can see myself playing this on and off like
uh on and off a lot um because apparently the the stuff you
can build is actually very elaborate uh so there's a lot of
like very elaborate stuff you can build overall um and I
feel like I'm just only in like 1% of the actual game in
general uh but um I definitely enjoyed it a lot um I think I
personally think this game lived up to its height because
the story itself seems really interesting like when you're
covering bits and pieces uh when you're you know like bits
and pieces of the lore and stuff and you find out like, you
know, it's a post-apocalyptic world of Pokemon.
You're like, what happened to all the you?
I just thought, you know, the human, like, I just thought
like, you know, the humans like just lost like their Pokemon
or something on this island.
Apparently it's not just this island.
The whole Pokemon world is like a nuclear wasteland now,
which I was like, what?
I was like, here's pallet town i'm like pallet town like
I'm like what do you mean oh I'm sleepy now I was like what
do you mean pallet town
so that was a huge plot twist which I thought was it was a
crazy plot twist I was not expecting it but yeah my honest
opinion I definitely enjoyed the game I'm not really good
tarot even as someone who doesn't tarot for him or like know
how to decorate very well I enjoy the like the quest like
you know I enjoy the quest and the progression of it I'm
pretty sure like if you guys enjoyed Animal Crossing you
like Animal Crossing you like Harvest Moon and stuff like
that you enjoy Minecraft I think you would like this game a
lot the only thing I'm bad I don't think I my only critique
for it is just the fact that like buildings seem really slow
um And very tedious, I feel like.
That's the only biggest issue I have is just that putting
stuff down and like constructing stuff seems really tedious
because you have to do it one block at a time.
But I think like if you have a lot of time to kill, if
you're patient, if you're a really patient person, you can
create something good.
Like I think you can create something really beautiful.
I'm pretty sure you can.
I'm pretty sure that you can actually recreate Palette Town.
in pallet town hey guys I'm gonna call it here um I hope you
guys enjoyed watching as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check yeah I've been moving around to get that blood
flowing um and you stay up for me head to bed cause you
deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye oh yeah before I go I almost forgot but uh I showed this
in members but uh The distributor and I agreed to like make
it the final version because it actually looks really,
really cute.
But we finally have a new update for the plushie.
For the members have already seen it.
But I also have something that members haven't seen.
But, um, this is what it looks like now.
Yay!
So this will be most like this is the finalized version of
the plushie.
And it looks super cute.
But there's more.
Wait, let me see.
I could get grab it real quick.
uh let's see there's more though but wait there's more i
just need to grab a screenshot real quick um we also have it
in the hoodies too yeah it's so cute it came out looking
really really cute and i'm happy with how it turned out in
the end uh it's here but here is where did i save it
here's the hoodie version we've been wearing the hood I
think it looks really cute too yeah so you can get it at my
dokeymerch.com we're still taking pre-orders you can order
it with the hoodie and yeah there's like the dad hoodie and
a dragon hoodie too I'll show you what it looks like the
dragon hoodie but you can grab it at the dokey merch
Dokeymerch.com.
And I love how it turned out in the end.
It's so cute.
Yeah.
I love the final version of it.
But here's the...
Here's the one with...
I think it was...
It's definitely an improvement from...
From the last draft to...
Definitely improvement from the first draft.
But yeah, here's one with the Dragoon Hoodie.
and here's one with the dad hoodie and here's i'll show you
guys again the uh from the last draft to now uh can we
pre-order unfortunately um um the very doki prime will not
be pre-orderable but in the future i am planning on
auctioning apparently they found the original doki prime
plush uh with like, um, the very first one, and I'll be
auctioning it off in the future.
So one lucky dragon will own Doki Prime.
They found the original Doki Prime.
It did not get scrapped.
So in the future, it will get auctioned off.
Uh, I don't know when it will be, but just giving you guys a
little heads up.
All right, so this was, I think, yeah, so this is the last
draft.
and this is the finalized I think it turned out I think it
was a huge improvement from the rarest doom yeah so left is
the last one that we made um and then the right is the uh is
the uh the finalized version I think it's a huge improvement
yeah I really love how the face and the hair came out in the
end.
But I'm super excited.
I'm super excited to see all the photos of people bringing
the travel size dokey everywhere.
You know, traveling around the world with a little dokey.
But I just wanted to show you guys that.
Yeah, I removed the nose.
No more smelling for this girl.
Yeah, I just felt like it looked weird.
Like, it looks like a smudge on my face.
Or you can just chuck it on the wall or like put it in the
pot i don't know how to boil it boil the dokey's like
um but yeah there's a little update with you guys about the
little dokey plushies i think they came out really cute i'm
super excited uh with the final i'm super i'm just really
happy with how the final version came out in the end uh with
all the uh with all the drafts we went through um And in the
end, it looks super cute.
I just wanted to show you guys this.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to head off for real now.
I'll see you guys next time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow, everybody.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.